nicki minaj is not having it
she's arguing with journalists they're
trying to get information on her family
so she published the private details of
i think two journalists i've only seen
one she posted some guy's uh business
card with his email and phone number on
it and now these journalists online are
like
how douchey she who do she think she is
we're journalists journalists are better
than you and i'm just laughing the whole
time because these journalists are
egotistical scumbags for the most part
and so they're whining and crying so you
know what i'm not going to shed a tear
from any of these people they lie about
nicki minaj they they go on cnn claim
she's she's scared of vaccines because
of swollen balls which is not what she
said they don't give you the nuance in
the actual context they just want to
make fun of people they just want to
smear them and make rage bait nikki is
waking up to this or maybe she already
knew and maybe she's finally speaking up
but she she actually said to like one
one woman like she called her uh i don't
even know if i'll i'll wait youtube has
a rule on swearing in the first 30
seconds so we'll read what she said
about this journalist and she was like
basically saying i'm coming for you but
in a more
aggressive way
and called her
a female dog so you know where that went
and i'm i'm you know what
i don't like
name-calling i don't like escalation of
conflict but it's also kind of a it
there is this this cathartic release
seeing these journalists you know
they're trying to go up against somebody
who's one of the most famous individuals
on the planet lie about her insult her
deride her and she's like
she's got weight to throw around so this
is interesting is nicki minaj the hero
we need to challenge the
authoritarianism she came out and said
the us is becoming like communist china
and now this
wow we got a bunch of other stories
though there's one really interesting
story that i talked about on my main
channel which is there's an article in
the atlantic where this historian says
he predicts a civil war
and the trump supporters will win
now that i found really interesting he
says ultimately an authoritarian
regressive reactionary you know
political system can't survive and i'm
like
what does that mean it'll last 20 years
30 40 50 60 70 80 90. yeah eventually
systems collapse i get it but bro came
out and said there's going to be a civil
war and trump will trump supporters are
going to win he said he thinks it might
start with the indictment of donald
trump that would be the crossing of the
rubicon and there's a lot to consider
there because ultimately i think the
difference between ancient rome and now
is that
the
the trump supporters are the people who
are just like peaceful divorce take your
state and go we don't care they don't
want to take control of it so we'll get
into all this stuff we're being joined
by matt palumbo you want to introduce
yourself yeah matt i uh i don't know
what else to say besides them today's
guest i uh run a website
outside yeah some guy from the street
that tim fan was kind enough to invite
me in uh no no i'm uh here to talk about
a new book i have out about george soros
or is coming out i should say um when i
run dan van gino's new news aggregator
by juno report.com um which is our
competitor to the george report which as
everyone here knows uh kind of blows
yeah it used to be good i mean 20 years
ago yeah i mean the problem too was the
site never really advanced um in fact
there was an article on the on the onion
like 10 years ago about drudge report
and it was like uh exclusive report uh
drudge has actually been hacked for the
past 20 years they're trying to make
this they're trying to make the site
look like [ __ ] um and you know so there
is um you know a that the site never
really adapted and then b there's been
this weird sort of left-wing turn um
sergeant or trump and
he might be sort of bouncing back a
little but overall it's gone left and
and you know he's hammers
his audience and no one really knows
what you know the story is behind that
well there you go word well thanks for
joining us we got you guys to see you
guys happy to be here on friday
beautiful friday night amazing weather
outside went for a walk down to the
river happy to be back nice nice
moonlight very sweaty yeah
there you go the moon hadn't gone down
yet but yeah because we're actually at
the top of a mountain
i got some what are those little those
needle i'll i'll think of the i'll think
of the word of this plant that i got all
over my feet these little needles metal
metal you walked barefoot i walked in
sandals through the nettles yeah i was
in there yeah we're we're
we're on top of a mountain here i think
we're like 150 feet up or more like no i
think it's way more than that it might
be like 200. when i was driving in like
every 10 foot there was like a no
trespassing sign and i was getting
progressively more nervous this is the
wrong house i'm totally getting well
it's not it's it's it's there's there's
two no trespassing signs so don't
exaggerate because after the second got
me lying after the second sign it's the
auto defense turrets uh yeah yeah
aggressively
so that's what i saw someone actually
once claimed that we had full auto 50
cal that's like cool like these people
are nuts like no that's not true it's
just a little sign says don't come in my
house
but sure we got lydia i loved this rumor
about like our auto defense turrets and
50 cal i was like this is cool why
hasn't tim told me about this i wouldn't
deny it i would just say yeah yeah you
totally have that yeah don't don't come
here
let them believe it all right let's talk
i'm so uh excited for this nicki minaj
story because it's just like
progressively getting better but before
we get started my friends we have an
awesome sponsor go to
surfinginternetsafe.com
to get virtual shield a virtual private
network service
virtual private network provides you a
basic layer of protection as you're
surfing the web it can help protect you
from hackers government spies
corporations
anybody who's trying to break in sniff
around steal your data and often it's
not even like someone's targeting you
don't think there's like someone trying
to you know crowbar open your computer
there could be just they throw out nets
hackers will just you know throw out
nets there'll be viruses there's big
corporations that are constantly spying
on you a vpn provides you that basic
layer of security it's like locking your
doors and windows and putting your
blinds down because you don't want
people to be able to see and you don't
want to break it in your house go to
surfing internet safe they say stay safe
with 50 off for life
you can also enjoy 24 months of online
security from the world's easiest and
fastest vpn for only 59.88 that's
actually 77 off and you get 50 percent
off all add-ons and other great
discounts on their other plans they're
also proud to announce that this month
all discounts are guaranteed for life
that means 50 off for as long as you're
a customer
and uh
it does say brought to you by timkes
virtual shield is our first sponsor so
we're eternally grateful they've been
around for a long time and go to surfing
internet safe the way i always describe
it is you don't expect someone to break
into your house but you still lock your
doors in windows so take your take your
security seriously
man i'll tell you this too
a lot of people don't realize they don't
even think about it until something bad
happens and you'd be surprised we
actually have had network attacks and i
don't want to get into too much detail
because it could risk our security but
there's stuff that goes on behind the
scenes where we're like yo we need to
consider this stuff because weird stuff
happens and i'll leave it at that and
you don't notice until you get an i.t
guy who's like yo and he shows you and
you're like whoa i didn't even realize
that was happening and it's bad so
you don't want that to happen you go to
surfing internetsafe.com but also go to
timcast.com become a member help support
our fierce and independent journalism
we got so much stuff going on with tim
cast ian's getting ready to do a cooking
show oh it's making me hungry just
thinking about it
cooking show i tell you the the
feedback's been great too i think people
are really excited the people who like
me are really excited to watch the uh
it's gonna be like it's gonna be like a
hippie trippy yeah
you know and what i'm gonna do is
take people's suggest they're gonna send
in recipes and i wanna do recipes from
fans and things too
i think that'll be really fun don't
forget to like this video this live
stream subscribe to the channel take
that url right now post it on every
social media website that you can that
you have help spread the word that's the
the network power we don't have a
massive cnn style marketing budget but
we do have all of you who support the
show so greatly appreciate it let's read
this story
i chose jezebel for our source perfect
on purpose
jezebel reports nicki minaj just tried
to dox two reporters it seems like she
isn't very happy about what's going on
there's a question mark there i don't
know i had to read it with the upward
inflection uh jezebel is a bad website
they're
not they're they're not a good website
but i thought it'd be interesting to
pull up jezebel because here's what i
find fascinating
jezebel's supposed to be like feminist
feminists right
supposedly feminist websites that's the
right thing why are they defending the
daily mail
isn't that in that weird so anyway
they prattle on for quite a bit and then
somewhere near the bottom they go on to
mention
she hopped on instagram and posted
screenshots to her story that allegedly
show a conversation between a reporter
in trinidad attempting to contact some
of her family members one assumes this
reporter must be doing so in order to
verify the claims of swollen balls but
we will likely never know the truth
because menage also used her story to
attempt to dox the reporters by posting
a picture of a business card a name and
a phone number and that it was a male
online business card
like it's a murdock company i'm
jezebel's feminist and they're all a
sudden difference these people have they
they claim like these these are bad
outlets and now all of a sudden they're
journalists okay sure whatever
but anyway for those that promote the
story
i'll give you the quick version nicki
minaj tweeted that her cousin
her cousin's friend
got the vaccine became impotent his
balls swole up and then his fiancee left
him which is like an absolutely insane
and ridiculous story i i personally like
based on everything i don't think that
anything with the vaccine but but nicki
minaj was just telling a story she heard
so okay journalists got all angry and
they started making fun of her she then
said two things she didn't want to
travel because of her baby
she then said the met gala wanted people
to get vaccinated and if she was gonna
get vaccinated it wouldn't be for the
met gala
then the narrative became nicki minaj
refuses to attend met gala due to
vaccine mandates and a fear of swollen
balls which we wouldn't really have but
right but it's just like it's over the
top and then she's like yo you're lying
i didn't say that
and the media what they do is they they
take what she said and twist it to the
legal extent they can without getting
sued but nicki minaj got 180 million
followers so she's she's going she's
going nuclear on these let me let me
show you what she posted
and uh
so well let's get rid of that
she says she posts one thread i'm not
gonna
read necessarily the the conversation
it's just like a journalist like their
names and stuff she says threatening my
family and trinidad won't bode well for
you
in trinidad harassing my family i didn't
want to give details but now i will and
this is a guy named james fielding we
blocked out his information they're
forcing my family to have to hide out
this is what speaking up looks like
millions of poor people are treated this
way by people you think are the good
guys this is unconscionable that one
well that was surprising to me because
she's now pointing out like these people
are bad guys huh they're claiming to be
the good guys or the bad guys she said
charlene ramper said [ __ ] your days are
effing numbered you dirty hoe
you know what i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna cheer for like
that level of
you know behemoths yeah but i will i
will say
fighting back that i respect like i was
gonna say like i'm against doxxing
people but the key word there is people
not internet hole monitors that's jobs
to do what these people are doing and i
don't know it's these people like see
all see themselves as gods to some
extent and i do think it's time they
sort of get some pushback and who better
than someone with a 100 million uh rabid
followers to join in that's exactly it
it's like final you know there's there's
a bunch of little guys out there who get
pushed around and lied about there was
that cnn story we were actually talking
about before the show cnn's like we're
gonna dox this guy if he posts a meme
one more time and it's like these these
are people are insane they target the
little guy and now they've gone after
nicki minaj who is the opposite of the
little guy she's a juggernaut yeah maybe
like celebrities we all don't really
like are kind of the are way forward
it's like the secret to defeat these
people i don't know well it's you see
all these conservatives that are like
cheering her on like yeah she's one of
us now and it's like no she agrees she
agrees on one issue like we don't have
to accept them fully but you know it is
nice when we can align here and there
she is one of us because whatever this
side is we're talking about the other
day the cult and the not cult that is
true i don't agree with conservatives on
a lot of things and like i i always like
to mention that i went on glenn beck's
show we're sitting in this big movie
studio basically because glenn beck's
the blaze offices are ridiculously
massive
and we have like this microphone hanging
down or whatever and we're arguing pro
choice versus pro-life with smiles on
our faces and a handshake and like wow
that was a really great conversation and
we're like yeah i thought the other day
too where i'm like i think with me like
if i had to you know start a new country
it's more the people and the policies
like i would rather have
our legislature but where we can
actually talk to each other and actually
converse and and instead of just you
know defaming each other and yeah do
what the left does where they reinvent
the meaning of words like i would rather
have a more sane populist with a
diversity of opinion than an only
right-wing country because i mean i
don't know what kind of right-wing would
be even and what are there what are the
people i don't like so that see what i
think is important
obviously that's never going to happen
there are some instances where i'll see
the right do something that i consider
to be disingenuous or just like
exaggerated or hyperbolic you know there
was one where recently happened joe
biden was like wearing sunglasses and
eating ice cream running around
and he said something like he was asking
about trump and he goes uh trump i don't
said
robert e lee
we
wouldn't afghanistan i don't want to
talk about it or whatever and they were
like look he's stuttering and mumbling
and he can't speak and i'm like no that
time it just sounded like he was sounded
like he was uninterested it's being
dismissive and was being dismissive yeah
you don't need to pretend that joe biden
can't speak we can all hear him say
tuning on a shot at a pressure
that's what it was but it's uh with with
the quote unquote right or the not cult
it's it's a mix it's independent voters
you've got like look you've got people
like jimmy dore right you know jimmy
dore's a socialist as far as i know i'm
not saying it to be
derogatory like i think he actually
identifies as a socialist and i think
jimmy's fantastic
and he points out a lot of the same
manipulations and lies in the media yeah
so
jimmy dore sitting down with a
conservative they're probably going to
be arguing like crazy but then they're
going to completely agree on the
establishment the feds the war the
manipulation so when nicki minaj comes
out and she's like the media lies and
i'm not going to stand for it's like yes
this is basically what we're talking
about the people who can who who are
discerning they look at the media and
they question the narratives and the
people who aren't who believe whatever
they're told so you someone so nicki
minaj tweets this thing like they're
lying about me michael malus tweeted at
her the corporate press of the enemy of
the people and then someone responded
nicki minaj's on the side of the far
right
here we go but that's that's the cult i
mean that's the weird thing about the
left too and making every common sense
position far right is like you're going
to actually normalize the far right
which is not necessarily something you
want to do either right but
it's not even far right michael it's not
at all i was thinking about how it's not
a volleyball game where it's like half
of us and half of us it's more like mold
toxicity has entered the system so it's
not like an aberration like it's there
and we can locate it it hits the system
and then it disperses throughout so
we've got these bits of like toxicity in
the system but it's a small percentage
of the system although it's affecting it
yeah and then every the rest of the
system is just functioning and now we're
all kind of trying to work together i
got a crazy idea you know get the right
to get on board with universal health
care and actually it's not even my joke
it's the babylon b trump trump comes out
and supports support of impeachment
forcing democrats to
yeah so i'm not even going to claim the
joke it's a recycled joke but yeah if
the right came out and they were like we
support the green new deal and aoc the
aoc is far right
because you can't convert people on the
right yeah politics
someone did that with cnn where i think
they were arguing for like paid
maternity leave and then ivanka trump
proposed not that policy but a tax
credit for for mothers and then cnn
wrote an article about why it was why
that was after a horrible policy
was the world we live in yeah the cult
that's why i call it the cult because
like we can i can sit down and have a
conversation about border policy with
libertarians and you have libertarians
who are prone for and against borders
and the people the libertarians who are
like open borders are the only true
libertarian position and the other
person is like no no there should be
borders at the west end of the country
and it's like
those conversations can happen yeah
we've been trying to get people to come
on with alex jones we want a leftist to
come on they won't do it
because they're scared of him not
because you know you know what the funny
thing is they're scared because he's
gonna be right because when joe rogan
had him on and joe rogan kept fact
checking him and then he joe would be
like alex that's not true and alex's
back look it up i'm telling you and then
jamie pull it up and then oh yeah i
found it it's true it's cnn reporting
2016 some weird thing when he was here
alex told me that we eat cloned beef
he's like all the beef you're eating
it's all clones and i'm like no it isn't
that's ridiculous and he's like look
google it and i typed it in and
dozens of articles
all of the meat you get is from cloned
cows and i was like oh so what happens
is we have these leftists some of them
are like yeah i'll do the show and then
later go no no i'm not gonna do it yeah
because what are they gonna do when they
sit down across from alex jones and he
says something populist like we can't
have these elites stealing money from
the working class and they're going to
be like i agree with you alex jones and
then that's going to get clipped yeah
and put everywhere they're scared
they're scared because
now i certainly think alice has been
crazy and wrong about a lot of things
well he's enough but i like the guy but
but when he talks about nobody wants to
be in the room with the guy these
leftists don't where they get a sound
bite where they're in agreement with him
over basic issues when he's talking
about 5g cell towers and mutant animal
hybrids and weird stuff it's
the left can't agree with the right on a
single issue
we can agree with a single issue with
nicki minaj and go yeah we'll align with
you there but like they'll find someone
they agree with on everything or or even
like they're canceling within their own
like like they'll find somebody growth
and everything and be like oh he said a
homophobic term and xbox live in 2003
and we got a you know oh what was that
the the jeopardy guy
yeah i posted nine i think it was nine
years ago
and then it's it's so weird too because
you see you can see it play out in
twitter the whole process and all the
other journalists like wow great job uh
transcribing this nine-year-old podcast
you know i knew about like great work
guys
yeah he said boobs or something it was
something it was something so
i mean i already forgot what it was
which would give you and you know dude i
i say it all the time but like i don't
understand how people would choose to
live that way like nicki minaj is
willing to put her career on the line
because she's like screw you i'm not
going to do what you say how is it nicki
minaj is more more punk rock than rage
against the machine
that's the thing with the left
they always have an issue no matter how
obscure like i'll be friends with them
on facebook from college and they're
like oh this native tribe in the middle
of this place you've never heard of
needs our help and i'm like how do you
guys keep track of all this [ __ ]
i'm not saying it's bad to care i'm just
saying i don't get how you guys it must
be exhausting i'm i'm looking forward to
like nikki doing new songs yeah because
she might incorporate oh it's uh it's
all gonna be red pills yeah and and
she's it's like you think back to that
line from rage against the machine
i'm sorry rage on behalf of the machine
where they said f you i won't do what
you tell me and now they're
they're lying we should rewrite that
song f you you better do what they tell
you and they're not they were never
really anti-establishment like if you uh
well they actually did a tour i think
was sponsored by pepsi once but um you
might want to check that but um on
tomorrow's guitar the the um the black
one i don't know what it's called i'm
not into music but um it referenced the
shining path which is a peruvian
communist group that killed 60 000
people yeah
so so that's the kind of people he's
publicly supporting i mean it doesn't
really seem uh all that
anti-establishment or you're rolling
against but when the establishment in
the us opposes communism they're
anti-establishment yes so
so that's the funny thing right you've
got some people who are who
this is what i've what what i found i
found uh i was having a conversation
with this hacker guy
relatively prominent prominent during
the anonymous era occupy wall street
and i was like we were arguing and i was
like dude you guys changed like we
didn't change we still believe in free
speech we still believe in all these
things and then he just was like yeah i
know we used you
like we were anti-establishment because
we want to subvert you know the the
authority and take over and install our
communist you know utopia
and you were willing to help us do it so
we tolerated it now that we have
institutional authority we don't believe
in freedom and we never did it was just
a means to an end yeah
that's that's the thing in politics in
general like people are only really
principled so as long as you know it
gets them into power um i think only the
right really stays principal but it's
almost to their detriment at certain
times like you'll see them be weak on
vaccine mandates for instance and say
well we can't really tell businesses
what to do or they'll go ahead no no i
should uh i don't want to drop trump i
didn't want to interrupt no no
i was going to i wanted to ask though um
because you might know this dude has
lauren bobert proposed repealing the nfa
uh i mean i assume not um but i don't
know the uh i actually follow her that
much so
someone may have look it up yeah i'm not
entirely sure but that's in that
national firearms act it bans tons of
weapons it makes it nearly impossible to
get specific specific guns that some i i
i think shouldn't even make sense to be
banned but there's a ridiculous amount
of guns that are banned people don't
understand that not only is there a
ridiculous amount of guns that are
banned but there's also a ridiculous
amount of guns that can't even be made
because of the nfa and other atf
regulations and rules
so so it looks like senator cramer the
u.s senator from north dakota introduced
a bill to abolish the nfa senator kramer
and colleagues introduced bill to
improve firearm owners access uh what
was just uh this is from june 2021 but
this is okay that's great
is that guy he's in right now and he's
doing that yeah i'm not i wasn't i
wasn't doing that to drag lauren bobert
by anybody anyway it's just because she
is very very much a two-way candidate
and i'm wondering like are the
republicans coming out and being like
you know we demand right
seemingly enough no
no yeah it's the thing the republicans
will get power then they'll go well if
you know we use the government to
enforce our principles the left will do
it when they take power and it's like
well they already are i mean
it's almost like a meme that schools are
left-wing it's like are you guys letting
me get that way but that's that's that's
the point yeah i'm not asking for low
and lauren bobert or any or margaret
taylor green any of these rand paul to
demand the government give us stuff i'm
saying repeal the law and let people
decide on their own but you know the
issue is
you got a game of tug of war with the
left pulling with all their might and
the right's just standing still yeah
they do tweet a lot though so you've got
the fear of not getting voted back in if
they anger too many people if they get
too loud so they're kind of like they
don't want to make a noise like i didn't
even know who that guy was you just
mentioned kevin graham yeah but there's
a lot of a lot of members of the house
you don't know but come on look at aoc
she stomps around yeah yeah i think
she's not one of those i think it's like
d plus 25 like basically you could run a
dead democrat against a republican in
her district and a dead person would win
unfortunately you could run a sawhorse
yeah i mean it's literally it's a you
know kim klasik level district so it's
not that i mean no that's that's the
crazy thing too and this is not an
exaggeration or a joke if you put saw
horse
saw space horse d
and you know john smith r
the saw horse would win
because people will just see the d and
then check it off regardless there's
some
town i don't know if i always saw the
headline but where i think a cat won the
mayoral election which maybe maybe that
was just a joke on the people's part
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
of small towns with only a couple other
people the vote for the dog
what's the point yeah yeah but i
actually think i wonder if if this can
be you know pulled off if you can
in
i wonder what would happen if you just
went to a district
got someone who's a republican on the
ballot as a democrat i've had that
thought like you run and you you
you lead with your issues that are
left-leaning and just you know kind of
stay quiet on the other ones but you
don't even it doesn't even matter if you
can get if if there's like some obscure
district and you run into d plus 28 and
you run as a democrat and you win the
primary
see the issue i suppose is running the
primary is very activisty because that's
where all the hardcore
activists are
but what's the stop a republican from
from doing you know pulling an aoc and
being like i'm far left and then getting
in and then go right to the i know this
is establishment this is just a sheriff
election but i think that's what i was
like david clarke the black sheriff he
used to be on fox news a lot um he's
very conservative but he is a debt
registered democrat i think it's sort of
the same thing he's in an area where you
kind of have to be even though what he's
saying is not that way um i think that's
the answer answer to the problem yeah
and so a republican runs as a democrat
and a democrat district and then votes
republican yeah i think no one pays
attention to those local politicians
right like i i mean i know who my
representative is i don't know who any
of the other ones are and i don't think
i i doubt half people in my town in my
town even know who theirs is so yeah i
think it would be possible
you know well that's the thing about uh
aoc's district she won the primary with
what was it like 11 000 votes
wow so imagine if right a republican ran
as a democrat
and told all of the republicans because
there's i think how many are there 200
000
or 120 000 republicans in aoc's district
i think is there yeah interesting it's
like 20 20
so it's actually a little bit more like
150 amen imagine if you got 20 000
activist republicans to vote in the
democratic primary for the conservative
democrat although was the 11 thousand
was that her
hammer or her like didn't she have like
a runoff with the incumbent or something
joe crowley i think i think it was aoc
yeah it wasn't a runoff she won the
primary oh that's what was it so that's
what it was 11 000 to the primary and
then and then and then she wins that was
it and now i don't know why it must be
misremembering something weird i don't
know it might have been i think it might
have been 17 000. oh you got 14. but
either either way the point is it was
like in a district of 750 000 that's all
you needed to win yeah okay republicans
run as a run as a centrist democrat just
vote and get all the republicans to vote
for you and then once you're in be like
oh i'm joining the republican party and
then you've got new york's 14 is a
republican district in new york
like uh like what was what was jeff
andrew oh yeah you saw that guy he was
in new jersey
he was a moderate democrat he won in 20
uh yeah he's flipped right yeah he
flipped because of the impeachment he
was like they're nuts yeah and uh did he
won again didn't he i think so i think i
think he's from i think he's south
jersey which is the more conservative
half of the yeah massive trump i'm
thinking like we're thinking like strip
the d and the r off the tickets try that
and then just but then just vote and you
have to know who you're voting for but
then it'd be whoever the coolest name
you get people would change your names
like lightning smash and then you were
heading towards camacho
yeah
maybe the age of the popularity contest
should be i'd make my my name like
election losers who would vote for me as
a joke nobody
yeah yeah oh yeah nobody nobody wins and
i gotta say i think it's still better
this is the slashing the d's in the
arctic
we would be better off if in deep red
and deep blue districts a random person
one
right i don't i really don't like the
people drop for the d or the r that
always bothers me
that's all they do there was a story of
the uh trans anarchist satanist in new
hampshire i think it was new hampshire
right i don't know that that ran as a
republican
and won
it was a primary though that's awesome
and it was because republicans are just
like yup yup republican republican and
then when the republicans these voters
found out they were like what i'm
outraged and the the trans anarchist
satanist said to them
you voted for me are they still a
republican to me now i don't know i
don't know but um i i thought that was
brilliant absolutely brilliant
send a message to these people who walk
in and go oh mitch mcconnell he's a
republican lindsay graham no yeah i know
the the the establishment republicans
are speed bumps for democrats and it's
intentional as far as as far as i'm
concerned what do you uh what do you
guys think about having more parties
because i i floated it in both ways
where i'm like on one hand like it
allows people to be more honest because
like actually like within the republican
party there's probably three or four
different factions um but on the other
hand it could risk making the country
more divided in that you know instead of
one the blue team versus the red team if
you've got eight teams that are it would
be a good thing you think about it but
it's not possible in first past the post
voting systems well that's that we would
it would need to be like europe where
you vote for the party and then whatever
percent they get you know
like the parliamentary system yeah yeah
where basically it's like if 70 of the
vote is for republicans then you're
going to get 70 of the seats i'm a
little ignorant on how they fill this
seat i don't know if the party picks
them or what goes on i think i think the
party i assume that's it but i'm not
sure yet
if we had
10 libertarian seats
in in the house it would force the
democrats and republicans to compromise
yeah i want like a libertarian party a
nationalist party like a i don't think
like a tea party party in the left can
have their you know crazy different
factions like a green party or something
maybe in a range of tsa or something
like that yeah right because look at it
this way there's uh bernie sanders is
notorious for compromising and working
with republicans and that's why they
called kamala harris the most liberal
member of the of of congress yeah so
not true it was just based on one year's
voting i think that particularly it was
it was based on cooperation bernie
sanders was willing to cooperate and
sponsor republicans in exchange for
their support on his bills and his bills
were substantially more progressive but
he knew where his paths were and kamala
harris was just not talking republicans
at all that doesn't make her fur further
left than bernie but that's how they
they weighed it yeah i think another
thing too was like bernie there are
certain policies of his there's
literally no point in proposing because
it's they're not going to go anywhere um
so obviously he has radical beliefs but
they don't show up in the record because
you know it's just never going to pass
you remember when bernie he said this i
think it was man when was this 20 might
have been 2018 he said he was asked at a
rally should we have open borders and he
said something like it's koch brothers
right yeah he went no no that was an
interview in 2015 he was asked at a
rally he went oh oh geez no like the
poor would flood into this country we
can't do that and so the world socialist
website called him a nationalist
capitalist
yep speaking of that
speaking of people flooding in the
country you see drew hernandez tech
tweet from today of that giant mob of
people coming across the border no it's
from the air uh you might be able to
pull up and then after that went viral
it didn't like they tried to ban the use
of drones they did that
they banned fox news flying drones over
that particular area so the local law
enforcement gave them a helicopter to
fly overhead so they could keep
recording i thought it was fantastic the
people on the border who live there the
local law enforcement they're like this
needs to be are you talking about the
ariel view one yeah ten thousand
migrants have congregated under a border
bridge
after crossing illegally reports fox
news
this is from del rio texas yeah yeah so
these these images are crazy and the
bite administration got the faa to shut
down airspace
apparently they're defying it drone
airspace i guess yeah so tucker said on
the air there he was telling them like
literally telling the guy don't obey
them right let me let me tell you guys
something
there's no united states anymore yeah
well we're not it certainly doesn't feel
united i mean
we're not a republic yeah we we've
talked about this couple days ago with
jack murphy
laws are created in this country now
over the past two years as the sovereign
decrees it and then the people are given
the right to challenge so long as
they're impacted by it the courts can
then strike down their challenge and the
law stands yeah that's what's happening
with all the chronovirus lockdowns
across the cdc stuff it's like they
should not have the authority to create
law and even when the supreme court says
so biden says i'll do it anyway yeah so
now we're in we're in a a government
where
governors
and the president just say
here's the law
and then the people go okay i guess
not only that i'll so that's why i say
we're not in a republic jack is murphy's
actually the one who said that but we're
not we're not a country anymore for one
simple reason
at the southern border in texas the
migrants are going back and forth i saw
them
i saw it it looked like that no they are
they're they're literally it's this is
this is the big news they're going into
mexico and they're walking back and
forth as if there's no border anymore
yeah well there really isn't i mean
that's it yeah so when it was
when we had a border
you have a country it's defined by
here's the border of our country where
our jurisdiction extends
then we started having problems with
illegal immigration so we started
putting up barriers and then trump says
you know we get to the point now we're
like we're going to build a wall because
we're asserting our right to have
jurisdiction that this is our country
this is where where our community lives
joe biden gets in and the crisis gets
worse but we identified as a problem
illegal immigration people coming in
this country are violating our borders
now it's been
a year you know it's been almost a year
it's been you know three quarters of a
year and joe biden
the problem's only gotten worse and it's
gotten so bad that the migrants are
actually crossing back and forth
so people will walk into the united
states go to the camp and hang out then
walk back to mexico for food and water
and go to stores and then walk back and
then sleep under the bridge as if there
is no jurisdiction at all anymore what
we're having i think there's like a
20-year high in apprehensions and
i assume because of biden we're not not
as much effort as even going into
apprehensions and despite that fact
we're at 20-year highs so it's probably
so much worse than we can even imagine
yeah i imagine joe biden sitting there
like is the country collapsed yet well i
mean the end goal is amnesty and the
left is always shifting the goal post
they'll go oh i mean we've 11 to 30
million people here we can't possibly
deport them all so the answer for them
is to do nothing and then 30 years from
now they can go hey there's 50 to 100
million illegals here we can't deport
them all and it's just it's endlessly
you know moving the goal post and then
trying to end with amnesty the you know
but the amnesty is is irrelevant uh
illegal immigrants give electoral votes
to states yep yeah so congressional
districts are on every story about that
just for people because we bring this up
a lot a lot of people don't know this
and it's one of the most important
points
congressional districts are drawn up by
population not by citizenry so the more
non-citizens are in an area which they
can just keep bringing in then
everything census comes out and they say
oh look we've got we need more districts
california and new york i think are
actually losing districts this time so i
don't know if you ever had any uh
run-ins with the fact checkers yet um
but my first was over that i did an
article and i was citing you know a
reputable study on how many
extravascular reps does california get
due to illegal immigration um and i
think it was four or five was what it
came out to so politifact wrote about it
i think it's one well i'll show you the
study um but um
their fact check actually i think was
two but so they do a fact check on me um
their response was it's mostly false
because it might actually be two or
three and i went to the evidence where
they debunked my claim they emailed some
professor right and he said oh i think
it's probably closer to two or three
that was literally the fact check was
some dude who's not even good
yeah they ask an opinion piece to act as
a fact check yep and then facebook gives
them the power to strike your business
and then like i think i emailed even the
math i'm like well here's you know the
average population of reps here's their
extra population so it should be this
amount and no effect i think it was the
heritage foundation said that california
ends up with one extra electoral vote
and college seat based on uh and and
electoral college votes and
congressional congressional seat based
on the population of illegal immigrants
yeah it was center for immigration
studies and to be fair they might okay
they might have also been factoring in i
think mine excluded this but they also
did one where they put in legal
permanent residence or non-citizens
because they also count uh and it also
you know generally benefits left-leaning
states i don't uh i don't i i think
man is biden's our buchanan you know so
either the united states is done already
we've got sarah silverman coming out
being like i think we should have a
country should break up they can be usa1
will be usa too and i'm like i did like
she would give us one though that was
very nice of her it was very nice but
she's independently come to this idea
she doesn't watch michael malus's show
and that's what he's been talking about
so for her to independently come to this
maybe it's time the country breaks up
i'm like yo when the left and the right
are basically like can we break up
please yeah then what's keeping it
together yeah the only concern i have is
i mean from our perspective and
definitely we're all politically
involved it feels like it's half the
country hates the other half of the
country but i think it also could be the
case that 20 of the country hates the
other 20 and then the remaining 60
percent like just want to watch the
bachelor i'm certainly one of those
other 60s
i don't think it's that big actually i
think it could be 10 and 10 even i think
the fact that you know joe joe biden
pulled in as many votes as he did shows
that they're regular people who just
believe what they're told now they do
just want to watch the butler bachelor
but they're also scared of the right
correct but so it's it's unique to
the whatever we would call the
establishment the left whatever you want
to call it in that
i know people that's what i told bannon
who had no business being in politics
like these are people who've never
watched a minute of news
all of a sudden posting videos of them
filming themselves dropping their their
mailing ballots for biden saying we all
got to vote for biden
that kind of zealotry is unique to the
left the right doesn't have that ground
game and that's why i think you know
like the recall effort could have
there were 1.7 million down
uh if you if you analyze the date i
don't know the exact numbers aren't now
but trump supporters didn't show up to
recall gavin i'm not saying they would
have won but they could have come out
republicans on the right don't have
ground game yeah and i think there are a
lot more uh michael miles would say a
lot more npcs on the left in that i mean
default liberal i think would brighten
people that's the thing like your
blinders growing up are every musician
artist
mainstream tv show comedian every sort
of facet of the entertainment industry
it's all left wing so when you only hear
one opinion you really can't blame
someone for just going oh okay this is
you know i guess what i'm told but it's
not even that it's the fear it's like
you're not right wing are you
and then when you're like yes
but not even that you're like no i just
think there was a viral tick tock you
know from libs of tick-tock oh it's like
where this woman's like dancing it's
like why i broke up with my boyfriend
it's like unvaccinated oh so that one
doesn't want the facts
is it vaccinated
doesn't like science and i'm like what
these people are insane i'm like you all
got to see in chemistry like what are
you pretending to speak to agree on the
vaccine science it's not even they they
don't believe in science i saw this and
i was like this is the crazy thing
when we say science we're talking about
analysis research control groups when
they say science they're talking about
authority well the thing too the phrase
i believe in science is an unhealthy
unscientific phrase you don't believe it
you you
know accept the data or or challenge it
and if you believe in it you're not
thinking yeah you're supposed to use
science to challenge itself exactly
there's a really great uh scene in
stargate sg-1 you watch that show was
that the show that was just on
downstairs
yeah well so i saw that one episode so
they they uh in one of the early
episodes they discover they go through a
portal to other worlds they find a group
of people who are highly technologically
advanced and
they consider us primitive like earth
that humans you know on earth are very
primitive and
carter is explaining schrodinger's cat
quantum physics and he laughs and he
goes and he calls it something else and
then she's like wait do you know quantum
physics and he goes yes we've uh we've
long learned of quantum physics and
other scientific misconceptions and she
goes misconceptions are you saying
you've thrown out quantum physics and he
laughs because like they're society
they're not supposed to share their
science with less developed but that
that was a really great point to be made
in a show from the i think the episode
was in the 90s that
we we can laugh at the fact that we
think we know things and then later on
we we continually better our
understanding and debunk and disprove
and refine our understanding so when you
have people saying
you i believe the science and i'm like
oh which papers did you read yeah well i
anthony fauci said on tv it's like yo
don't come at me and say that we our
research from reading articles is wrong
when i literally read the scientific
papers on these different things and you
did nothing it's a cult and with and
this is more medical science but there's
a vox stock so they did an article on
like studies proving and disproving that
something's good for you so they'll have
like chocolate i have a list of every
study that says it's good and everyone
that says it's bad and like for every
possible thing it's 50 50. yep um now
obviously that's a medical science is
much harder to control for all that
stuff so it's different than you know
physics or something but it is
interesting i don't see how uh because
we had this this argument the other day
there was a point where i felt like we
could mend the divide maybe 20 maybe
2015 2016 where it's where you know i'm
saying like we need to make sure we're
we're understanding each other and
explaining things in the right way and
if someone is saying racism is prejudice
plus power then all we got to do is
break down what these words mean and try
to come to an understanding now we're at
the point where it's like yo people are
wishing for death on each other well we
can see we're at a point where we can
all see the same viral video and
somehow predictably you can predict
someone's reaction to it or like you can
know someone's opinions on guns and know
their opinion on abortion like there's
all these things that really shouldn't
be but
but i'll tell you where the line is and
this is why i say the left is a cult and
whatever
you want to call this amalgam of
different factions is not
remember the acosta jim acosta had the
microphone and he was trying to and the
and the young
white house intern tried to take it from
him
the the establishment people were
arguing that she tried yanking it from
him and the right tried arguing that
acosta
like tried yanking it back from her
and
i think you can clearly see
that acosta was the one take yeah
amusing the force but my position was
i don't know exactly if jim acosta was
trying to yank it from her or if he was
just like
regardless jim acosta should not be
fighting with an intern no matter who
was in the right or wrong jim acosta
should have handed the microphone over
and i had high profile
personalities dm me i'm not gonna say
who it was and be like are you being
serious with this right now and i was
like
serious with what you really sang it's
his fault and i was like
why why was he standing up there talking
for two minutes and when you're in the
white house as a guest when the intern
comes up to take the microphone from you
you say well here's your microphone back
but they they don't care they literally
are like that's why i say it's a cult
it's not about whether it's true or
false it's not about whether it was a
cost as fault or the intern's fault it's
about do you agree with me or not and
even if i say i don't necessarily agree
with the conservatives on this one but i
still think it was wrong that acosta was
even in that situation in the first
place he should have just had he should
have handed it right to her and they're
like no you're wrong you're in a you're
you're the guy and if it was peter ducey
and like biden a woman for biden we get
like a 3 000 word think piece i'm like
oh the challenge is that female white
house interns have always faced in this
country and what are we gonna do about
it i've noticed like if someone posts
something and then i'll respond like
like tim will say something and i'll
write yeah right on on his comment other
people will read that and they'll be
like he said look at that sarcastic jerk
yeah right and the age of text is very
new for humanity oh i had a roommate who
would always drop like trolling comments
on my post and fans of mine didn't know
who he was so they would always get
angry at him and he thought it was
hilarious the problem is if i'm not
trolling if i really mean yeah right
what you're saying people will see that
and think i'm being sarcastic and
misinterpret and that's caused massive
confusion you know i i tweeted um
we should ban fat people
from hospitals
so that we can we can protect the
healthy yeah
yeah it's about if you choose to be
unhealthy then we will not give you a
hospital bed just like with people
aren't vaccinated and the tweet got
thousands of retweets and i have people
responding with i may be fat but i'm
healthy and have never spent a penny in
the hospital and then and then the guy
goes you're being sarcastic like he
responds again
you're being sarcastic aren't you like
it it was a tweet the purpose of the
tweet is you said you gotta understand
about when you're when you when you do
trolling well
it was not a serious tweet i am not
literally calling for fat people to be
banned from hospitals
i'm constructing an argument that puts
them in a principled predicament if they
say well the reason we think the
unvaccinated shouldn't be given hospital
beds is because of triage
then i start with fat people should be
banned because of triage like the
un-vaccinated right yeah and it forces
often when i do these tweets the left
can't even respond
because it would shatter their their
narrative it applies to a little like
almost any reason you'd be in a hospital
like you could break your leg in a
skateboarding accident are we going to
say oh well you shouldn't have taken
that risk so it's your fault i mean and
it also sort of undermines their case
for universe
universal healthcare and that if these
people were in charge of it
it seems like they're going to be sort
of nitpicking who and who's allowed to
have it look what they're doing with
florida yeah joe biden takes away some
of the monoclonal antibodies
well we got to give to other people and
it's like why the other states aren't
ordering it right florida is ordering it
because florida needs it why would you
take them away because it's punishment
let's let's talk about this because i
want to show you this article i got from
the atlantic
this is a series this was an article
published august 13th it's a series on
ancient rome in the fall of the roman
republic and it's uh really really quite
interesting now this guy running for the
atlantic it's a mainstream media thing
it's a left left wing so he basically
says the trump supporters live in
fantasyland and the reactionaries
clearly doesn't like trump supporters
but here's what he says
will the trumpest party similarly
ultimately prevail once they cross the
rubicon i have been predicting for years
that something resembling a civil war
will arise and something like trump
trumpists likely will carry the day in
the short term but a reactionary
philosophy that rejects fact in favor of
fantasy is economically retrograde and
socially repugnant to the majority of
americans
can impose its rule only for so long
you know what's really funny about that
when you take out the fact that the
trump supporters are not the ones who
believe in fantasy but typically are the
ones who are critically thinking not all
of them they have their zealots what
he's basically saying is the trump
supporters will win but we hold again so
yeah but the ins but the the military
and the cops have guns too this is this
is one thing that doesn't seem to
understand you know i see these comments
all the time they were like how is the
left going to win a conflict when the
right of the ones are the guns i don't
know the right's the one that they're
leaving the military the officers are
resigning and quitting the police force
and leaving in the establishment shills
who are armed
but in this if you if you if you're
operating under the presumption
that trump supporters are going to win
and then say but they can't hold power
for long because you know insert
disparaging comments about trump
supporters okay well
if you look at the right if you look at
the the the thought leaders on the right
they're typically critical thinkers
they're biased like daily wire is
conservative by a site but they don't
post lies
then the reality is it's the left that's
retrograde and reactionary and in favor
of fantasy they think the economy is
good right now no so so what what
they're really saying is
this guy based on his assessment of
ancient rome and what's happening now
thinks there will be a civil war and the
trump side will win
i wonder too like when people say civil
war do they literally mean for the
entire country or do they just mean like
in some region of it you know will be
taken over because like it would be the
entire country like so we just got to
claim alaska and hawaii somehow it's
just no it's not a package sure so what
people the problem with americans is
that their view of civil war is based on
one of the most unique internal
conflicts in history the american civil
war was a union of states of different
jurisdictions aligning against each
other whereas most civil wars are
factions fighting everywhere in the
country at the same time so if you look
at the spanish civil war and see like
the different pockets that emerged of
the net the republicans versus the
communists or whatever and then they're
fighting each other and then gaining
more and more ground and eventually they
take over i think spain went you know
military dictatorship or whatever
that's like oh okay that's how the civil
war operates but americans are like
there was the mason-dixon line and then
west virginia became a state and
virginia separated and it's like
that's because each state was basically
a country right with a sovereign state
and so when the union got shaky states
seceded of their own accord without
what other states thought and then
because of the conflict the confederacy
joined forces to defend themselves
against the union that's why they called
it the war of northern aggression was
there a big call from the citizenry to
to go to civil war the american civil
war was that all like a government i
think it was a government all the
governors were just decided right not a
governor thing i think it was a
government thing
the legislatures and i think regular
people didn't want it but nothing could
be done i mean first and foremost
slavery here's the other difference
between a a modern civil war and the
passive war
you can argue
and and i think this is i agree with
this that slavery was so morally
repugnant going in to stop slavery was
a cause in unto itself
meaning
if we had a state right now that was
like
enslaving people i would be demanding
the federal government like we cannot
tolerate in our own country it's a
violation of all of our rights and it
must be ended immediately and so i can
certainly understand why the north was
like we're we're not going to let these
states do this first of all we they had
continually passed laws that were like
we're going to get rid of slavery and
the south was mad about it and wanted to
leave the union
war breaks out but when you have that
moral issue and i think everyone
everyone agrees like you know and it
it was a good thing to end slavery that
grief slavery was really bad
that's the thing like name a person
right now i'm sure there are some
crackpot you know
individuals and racists who are like
angry about it but 99.99 of everyone
agrees
it turned out properly it was the right
thing today we do not have that moral
issue our moral issues are like i live
in the mountains of west virginia and i
want to own a gun well i'm from new york
and i think you shouldn't be allowed to
have one
could you imagine
that makes no sense there's no no one's
going to invade west virginia to end the
the moral repugnance of gun ownership
and no no no from west virginia is going
to go invade new york to stop them
they're going to be like what's going to
happen is
washington's going to be like
we out yeah i also have this thought too
in my various streams of secession i had
this thought that like i think the
biggest of it too is urban rural in that
even if a state were to succeed its
population center is probably still
going to be left-wing and still have
outsized influence even if you know
people you know in the majority of the
square mileage of it or right-wing so
and i know this will never happen like i
don't know if it would make more sense
to have you know sort of city states for
liberals and then you know everything
else for the conservatives
yeah they'd fall into seconds i think it
is true that even in west virginia the
states are are blue it's the craziest
thing people should check this out come
to west virginia go to central west we
were in central west virginia in some
small town in the bars got the trans
rainbow flag
and i'm like we're in central west
virginia
and i'm like i don't understand why er
even small urban centers become leftist
the internet you know yeah the internet
yeah i mean there's actually a really
interesting book by jonathan height and
he points out that conservatives and
liberals actually have different brain
structures and that we i mean we are
just fundamentally different and it
could just be naturally people with more
left leaning and progressive views tend
to concrete among other people and
weaker people who need support and want
to mooch off others and conservatives is
kind of like you know space and like
there have been polls and it's like with
conservatives would you rather have to
drive 10 minutes to get somewhere or
walk you know 10 minutes and most
liberals will say oh i'll walk to the
store most of the servers would prefer
the drive um and those traits just kind
of self-select you into that kind of
lifestyle yeah um yeah jonathanites
research is fascinating
liberals have only two of six moral
foundations yes care and fairness
conservatives have all six and
libertarians only have one
what is it what's theirs liberty oh
that's it yeah it's amazing the only
thing yeah so there's you can take these
tests to weigh your moral foundations
and uh
when i take the test it comes up left
liberal
but it's because i have a little bit
more care and fairness and then a slight
balance across the board liberty care
and fairness for me are really really
high and i think that really makes sense
i'm like i'm left with a lot of policy
issues but i'm
i favor more liberty which means i'm
typically in opposition to the
authoritarianism and then when it comes
to the other moral foundations i do have
them more than the average liberal
but watching libertarians take the test
because some of these questions
like i can't even say what some of the
questions are
like
oh man there's there's questions about
incest yes oh yeah and so libertarians
are like
zero on these other more foundations and
liberty is a hundred because they're
like i don't care what you do get the
government out and i'm like
i don't i i've got yeah cause there's
there's purity there's a thor there's
loyalty there's authority liberty care
and fairness i think are the you know so
purity is like
there's a reason for that moral
foundation because and i i was reading
about i think purity has a lot to do
with disease
that people who didn't care about like
debauchery
would be more likely to spread diseases
so you end up with
certain traditions emerging of being
clean and being you know you can see
like in religion like not even shellfish
it's like well at that time it actually
was a pretty you know brilliant
suggestion yeah at pork yeah yeah which
i've you know broken but
yeah yeah yeah well now we we've we've
gotten better at you know cleaning and
cooking and everything so it's safer but
you can see those those things still
exist but i'll i'll add one thing to
this too you know i don't know exactly
what happened in in terms of civil war
but i can say if we have two distinct
cultures forming in this country laws
cannot be enforced period so the example
i give is that i don't if you've ever
seen these books it's like wacky laws
the u.s does oh yeah there's a million
of them yeah but why don't we enforce
those laws like
like you can't you can't take showers on
tuesdays and you know rhode island yeah
we just know intuitively it's absurd and
i mean at the time it made sense
yeah so
i'm not saying rhode island literally
bans showers but there are places in the
east coast that we're like you can't
shower on tuesdays why well maybe
because tuesday was the day they they
allotted to the farmers to get access to
the fresh water so they could you know
from their crops and you couldn't be
well and then there's some there's some
things where it's like you can't uh put
pies in the window sill on sunday
mornings maybe it's because sunday
mornings is when the church would come
and it would attract animals and then
there'd be people around it would cause
problems and no more putting your food
on the windowsills to cool because the
animals come and but now it's the
animals are gone
and people are going to church less and
we have you know we just don't have that
problem anymore so culturally we just
ignore that law now what happens when
you have two distinct cultures
and then you have a law in the books
which is like gums it happens a lot
actually yeah what's that law the uh
it's old that old law that they were
like are they going to invoke the
insurrection act is that what it is some
old old law
yeah about like not sending a spy
overseas or something
the guy that the act is actually named
after lobby the foreign government after
the act was passed so it didn't even
deter him when it was passed
yeah they tried to get michael flynn on
it it was uh it makes no sense it's
never been used not to play my own work
but i did a book where there was a a
section of it with one genome is it what
is it isn't there an argument that mark
milley may have violated the logan act
um he was he was he was
discussing us military policy with
foreign adversaries i mean i would say
yes but it it won't matter in that it's
never you know been enforced so and
that's that's where it comes down to
yeah if republicans
actually had power no republicans the
wrong word lindsey graham wouldn't do
anything if conservatives trump
supporters had power hillary clinton
would be indicted
uh tons of the russiagate people all
these people who lied would be indicted
per like just across the board for all
the lies they put out they'd find
something you got that one lawyer who
lied alphabet was his name sussman is
that yeah yeah yeah wow i mean
debunked that like four and a half years
ago and it's just funny like the news
cycle where i'm going oh we were right
about all that's kind of cool
a lawyer fabricated evidence he claimed
that like this there was a server in a
trump tower that was communicating with
a russian band called alphabank uh and
it turned out to just be complete
[ __ ] basically
and hillary clinton was tweeting it and
john podesta was tweeting it and all
these journalists were like trump's
secret server and it was i mean the
whole the whole um michael flynn with a
logan act he was called while he was on
vacation um the people who called him
knew his cl knew that they were gonna
sorry he knew he was gonna be getting
called by a russian ambassador because
he's on vacation there's no way from the
event his call being intercepted so the
whole thing's getting recorded and then
it the you know that's what it led to
his downfall under trump and they
started like mentioning the logan act
and i'm going well why would you mention
the logan act to get to take this guy
down when it's never been invoked only
if this whole thing was planned so you
could try to find some sort of reason to
get rid of the guy look and it worked
you look at everything we talked about
already the borders so porous illegal
immigrants are going back and forth
there's no there's no border biden's
watching it crumble the economy's in
shambles the the system of of
the separation of powers is completely
gone and we had in the past five years
fake indictments or or i mean literally
against
political uh uh a political party a
political group for the sake of power
and we don't even really have three
branches anymore because as we were
talking earlier the cdc is just creating
a lot of thin air and other agencies and
there's and it's up to us to say
actually you can't do that and when the
supreme court told biden the eviction
moratorium was illegal he went i'll do
it anyway and the supreme court could do
nothing to stop him
so you look back at the russia gate
stuff and i think a lot of people said
the country was done when that stuff
came out michael flynn goes to an
informal meeting at the white house
and he gets asked so did you talk to a
russian uh ambassador and he goes no no
and they go okay then later they come
back you lied to us that's a crime it
was actually a bit
more complicated than that so they bring
him in for questioning
as they're questioning him they have a
transition that was informal though like
it wasn't yeah it was like two guys it
was peter struck on someone else um so
they'd bring him in for questioning and
he didn't know he was being investigated
no so he's bringing him for routine
questioning and he did admit to the call
he told all the contents of the call and
they as they're questioning him have a
transcript of the call in front of them
meaning they're not asking him to get
the truth of what happened they're
trying to see if he's trying to deviate
and then they report back no there was
no irregularities
and then somehow in the chamber of
command and i have no idea how it
changes to he lied about his call even
though the agents had no singing and
there was that document that came out
where like clapper and biden had a
meeting and they were like how can we
get this guy yeah it was the democratic
party what they did with russiagate and
what vinman did with ukraine
these people
are man i don't even i don't know the
right word uh it's it's sedition like i
honestly like when i first started
writing spygia i was like you know this
will be interesting but like you know i
it can't be that crazy and uh it turns
out like you know the sort of like type
of politics you see in what uh like in a
movie is actually more real than you'd
think let's break this down yeah
donald trump is on the phone with
president of ukraine and he says
something off the cuff about like you
see this what's this thing going on
about biden and and this quid pro quo or
something why don't you guys look into
that yeah trump clearly had no idea what
was talking about this phone call but
what happened was a viral video where
joe biden's at where was he at it was um
was it it wasn't the council on foreign
relations no it was uh
i can't remember the
and said look if you don't fire the
prosecutor you're not getting the money
and he said you you don't have the
authority to do that and he goes call
the president yeah well son of a [ __ ]
six hours later prosecutors fired yeah
so trump hears about this asks the new
ukrainian president like well look at
this joe budden had not announced any
political ambitions and then everyone
said trump was going after his political
rival and we were like but biden's not
running for president this call i think
or i think that was in september that
trump had this call and people were
saying he threatened to withhold
military aid but the military aid was
actually had been withheld since i think
january or february for other reasons so
so here's what you need to understand
ian yeah that was the council on foreign
relations on formulations where he said
it
biden admits
braggs that he said he would withhold
foreign aid in exchange for getting a
guy fired the the media said but we we
do this all the time we pressure
countries for this reason
so when donald trump says i want you to
investigate what happened with this
they called that a quid pro quo even
though trump didn't ask for anything
so here's what really happens they claim
that donald trump was abusing his power
by trying to
use ukraine to go after his political
opponents what really happened was that
joe biden
shut down whether on purpose or not an
investigation multiple many
investigations but some into barisma
where his son happened to be on the
board
michael zlachevsky the founder of
barisma had fled ukraine
biden comes and gets the prosecutor
fired luchevsky returns trump comes back
in and says i want this investigated
zlatchevsky flees again
but the media comes out and says trump
was the criminal
joe biden flew on air force two with his
son to china to negotiate a private
equity deal but trump's colluding with
russia michael flynn
who's i think he's talking to sally
yates and he said she's the one who sort
of she's when he first pitched the maybe
he voted for the logan act leading me to
believe she's behind it he said i think
china is a greater adversary than russia
and then all of a sudden she was like oh
jeez oh no
he's colluding with russia trying to
downplay it the reality is i think china
according to mike pompeo has infiltrated
every level of our country in government
that's what he said
you've got the thousand talents program
where they're actually hiring our own
professors to give away our research
back to them
you've got chinese individuals being
caught carrying infectious diseases and
creating them and
bringing them illegally through the us
and then strangely
when michael flynn
says i think china's a bigger threat all
of a sudden there's alarm bells going
off the democratic party and they seek
to then get indictments and russiagate
was fake it was years where even i was
like well this is interesting we should
absolutely look into this and then
afterwards it's over rachel maddow's in
the verge of tears
listen you didn't understand when i say
these people are evil dude oh and and
the npc default liberals who line up
behind them and in the millions to vote
for them because they're in this matrix
this is a whole new this is there's a
level of depravity that can be described
in words
after the hillary uh emails came out i
was just like gob stopped gob smacked it
like the sydney blumenthal osprey osprey
global solutions libya contracts like
that she was pushing for her buddy
sydney and nothing you know and i was
like wow he's real but then trump won so
i was like oh maybe tyrion's not oh what
did they do to him and then what did
they do oh can i the first anti-war
president of of people's lives
can i can i just point out that um
wouldn't it be wouldn't it
okay imagine you lived in a country
and a high-ranking
cabinet member in the executive branch
had a non-profit
that was taking in millions of dollars
from foreign governments
and the pro that profit was named after
this individual in the in in the in in
the cabin in the executive branch
i mean surely that would shock people to
their cores when say like imagine saudi
arabia was giving tens of millions of
dollars to this and we'll call it the
the blinton foundation just as you know
while they're
secretary of state and uh we'll call it
the blinton secretary and uh yeah you
get the point the bliton foundation and
then as soon as the uh uh
this individual doesn't win the election
very corrupt very very corrupt and that
was the first time the email scandal was
the first time i saw it very clearly
very because it was very obvious if you
looked at the emails and you looked up
sidney blumenthal and you want to look
at like she was directly instructed by
obama not to work with sydney and she
was just doing it because he was an old
clinton advisor for like 30 years he's
worked at the clintons
it's it's it's terrifying it doesn't
mean that it's impossible but i mean
cryptocurrency and the underground
movement is is very promising but
politically it's it's terrifying these
are interesting times yeah and the
powers in the media which is why shows
like this are so cool
yeah we're fighting an uphill battle
that's for sure but i will say as the
the the challenge the establishment
faces is that they're they're losing
control so ultimately i think everything
might lead to some kind of balkanization
regional breakups and they can't do
anything about it you know so uh earlier
i saw you know you guys were doing the
fetiverse meeting
and i was talking to andreas about it so
for those that aren't familiar we
pitched this idea ian and the crew have
been working on us with the big team the
idea is to create an open source
software that allows you to have your
own website social media presence
subscription service that's networked so
no one can ban you anymore because it's
your website but your website does
connect with the network so if you go to
my site you can see a twitter feed and
each individual tweet comes from an
individual's own private server
unbannable
and so we talked about this and i was
like sooner or later someone's got to
try to shut this down because this would
like if we actually get to the point
where we have mass adoption of imagine
you owned your own private patreon where
you had subscription service you could
post a video feed you could post tweets
and it would actually link and people
and people could follow you across
different networks the technology
already exists it's called the fetaverse
gab is on it and now we are ramping up
and trying to create website
applications so that can be really easy
for people to use imagine we get to that
point where the powers that be can no
longer censor the news about hunter
biden because the network is totally
decentralized and i'm like someone's
going to have to try and stop that right
because it usurps facebook's power and
then the conversation was just how would
you do it it's a decentralized project
no one person is running it it's open
source code who do you go after to stop
it you can't and because technology
already exists they can't stop crypto
either there's nothing they can do
ultimately the end result is going to be
that they lose the ability to to
manipulate the media they lose the
ability to create the propaganda and
then it's just free-for-all
the only thing i can think of to do with
crypto is sort of on the the i guess
when you're cashing out because you need
to go through a legitimate brokerage to
convert the cash but if you're never if
you're never going to get her at the
cash you don't yeah
yeah you use like tethers or not tether
i think they're kind of fraudulent i
think bitcoin's one of the pegged uh
legal currency and uh salvador you don't
need to go through if you have crypto
and the crypto has value that's it look
we got these little obsidian rocks that
you eat and you brought this up i love
these things yeah yeah we all got one of
our hands if this is value enough for
you i can trade it with you and i've got
to go now we should make an mft okay
ian's obsidian stones
very excited about the future of nft
it's the nft revolution is upon us it's
like how cool bitcoin was in 2011 so if
you're paying paying attention to nfts
now keep paying attention get involved i
mean it's just a new form of data
transmission i like it what's it called
like er one seven or something or yeah
it's an erc one sump 170 is it
it's not erc20 it's a different kind of
erc token nfts are going to be awesome
because we're talking we're we have a
top secret project that we're
creating and the idea is nfts are unique
non-copyable digital assets non-fungible
so this means that we're gonna be able
to create digital hard assets that are
completely unique and so we're working
on some projects as for like people
posting photos and then selling it for
50 grand i'm like that's right i just
don't get who these people are buying it
uh who's got 50 who's got this
i assume it could just be some guy who
like made a bajillion dollars in bitcoin
and this is just yeah where do you spend
your trip crypto well on nfts basically
that's one way to spend your crypto i
think uh to trade your crypto basically
you know just in line with what we were
saying about
like the country breaking apart with
crypto
no one needs the federal reserve you
know and not only that el salvador was
one it was one of the smartest things a
country could have done especially a
country with us with you know it
not as wealthy as say the united states
because now that they're getting all
their citizenry to use bitcoin bitcoin
is going to keep going up in value yeah
it's also helping them too because their
their um
economy is dollarized um and they're
they're losing constantly losing dollars
due to imports versus exports and they
can't print any more money so this kind
of also works around that problem before
well they can't print bitcoin yeah yeah
but the thing is when a citizen holds
point one bitcoin because they're
planning on using it and the next day
bitcoins up ten percent yeah they get
richer yeah and so it's like imagine how
well off the citizens are going to be
now yeah because they're going to get
paychecks in bitcoin they kind of get on
the ground floor of other countries are
going to follow a lead i assume what
concerns me is when you see the entire
crypto space the 2 trillion cap dip by
40
all of it over the course of three weeks
like it's driven down 30 40
because some big probably governments
chinese governments americans are bought
or selling it and selling and selling it
make it want to drop and then as soon as
it drops they buy it all all these poor
people thought they were losing their
money it's not as bad though as when you
sell it and then it goes up 40 or 50
percent right exactly it's being
manipulated heavily and that's bad for
the poor people but these people got to
learn and we keep saying it when there
was that last big crash from 60 to 30
most of the sales were a couple hundred
bucks it was the poor people cashing out
panicking that's i actually bought
bitcoin because it crashed to 30 and
then paul krugman wrote an article about
why you should never buy bitcoin and i
went all right i'm in yeah well he's
wrote a lot of those yeah if i took his
advice you know 10 years ago i would be
uh much wealthier max keiser man he told
me when bitcoin was like at a couple
bucks give me to a friend you got to buy
bitcoin i'm telling you tim you want to
be rich hang out with me and i was like
okay i was up on a roof in brooklyn with
bill and a couple other guys and one of
the guys was saying dude the next big
one is ethereum you got to get into
ethereum and we're like what's then
what's okay when i looked and i was like
i waited a couple weeks and i was like
oh it's 10 bucks already it's too late i
can't get into it yeah i know it just
didn't didn't click until a couple years
later uh bill ottman was here i think in
like november what right bitcoin's at
13k ethereum was at a thousand and bill
was like you should buy ethereum dude
and i was like you thinks like you
should get something and i'm like okay
and then i bought a bunch and now it's
at like 335 or whatever
yeah because if ethereum is worth nfts
like ethereum is
ethereum is the evolution of bitcoin it
covers so some friends and i actually
started one as a joke and it has a 1.4
million dollar market cap
but it's it's so misleading because
there's like 30 grand in liquidity so
like obviously it's not if you could
sell through it but on paper it's worth
like 1.5 million so uh i own
i have some doge because it's fun
i have bitcoin ethereum and cardano i um
my and alex want a strategy i own like
uniswap sushi swap and then basically
all the tokens that are exchanges
because my logic was like well even if
the coins go down like as long as
there's volume the you know the
exchanges are making money yeah you just
swap my own a lot of the milestones
there's so much so much so much money in
unis people understand when you open
like these apps like coinbase it's like
you can earn interest on your crypto and
i'm getting like seven percent it's
insane it's not like gemini uh it's um
in exchange like the winklevoss twin
started they're giving you like seven
percent on their gemini dollar and i'm
going yeah i don't get how that's even
possible
no no it's really really simple yeah
these are uh so for those that
understand you you basically
you have crypto you can stake it being
like let me put my cryptocurrency into
your pool which allows them to do
transactions that's how ours works they
need liquidity when the transaction
happens you get a fee just like an atm
machine so you know i was actually
talking to my accountant and i was like
it's kind of like an atm someone comes
in they punch in their keys and they
take cash out and then
i get i have got a fee on it i get a fee
on it so this is create it's
this is huge it's going to make a lot of
working class people
i'm not going to say rich but
comfortable yeah yeah yeah so like the
stories of people who start with start
small and just keep putting more crypto
back into the system and they're
building up that portfolio it's kind of
crazy because so long as the it's like
basically the power of the central banks
in the hands of regular people and
decentralized so now the the money
transactions and printing and and
it's it that's just mine day trading
because the da it never ends it's 24 7
trading like if you're a 14 year old and
you want you get some money you want
you're going to play addict isn't the
best thing you've ever easily increased
you're like 30 your profits and just by
looking at trends and reading white
papers and seeing what's the next big
cool currency i am not advising anyone
to do anything
but
i would be willing to bet if there's a
14 year old right now who was given like
100 bucks by their grandpa
and put it into one of these systems and
kept putting all of their their fees
back in by the time they were 20 they'd
be a millionaire eric finneman it's the
guy who started the freedom that is him
that's exactly right yeah i think he
looked at grandeur too and now has like
you know like 10 million something very
high in the millions
as if you're paying attention you can
really take the light because it's
always up down up down and i mean you
just follow those leaps you have the
bitcoin you put it in the usd coin when
it drops it is hard you got it i mean i
think for the average person i think is
buy and hold just because you'll go you
know insane right
but yeah there are some people who know
what they can do i mean i tried that and
uh you know missed out i was day trading
for a while but it became very
exhausting because it's a it's a lot of
work
uniswap stuff is where the real
opportunity is yeah it's there's risk
because you're put you're you're staking
your coins to someone else's pool and it
could it could easily be yeah
it could go belly up well that's how it
works so we had to put our own money
into the pool with our own token um and
i mean it's our own coin is sort of thus
dependent on the value of ethereums you
have to match it to like create the
value and of course i can just sell all
the way through if they want to um so
yeah it's risky obviously
so if you find a good utility token with
with ethereum and you you put it into
uniswap
then you're set so it's it's basically
you've stu you you bought an atm that's
why imagine if you had 50 grand you
bought an atm you need another i don't
have an atm cost like 20 20 30 grand
then you need 40 grand to fill it you're
spending 70 000 you put the atm in in a
bar and then you're just getting free
money yeah could we get an atm here
why technically we could we could we
could invest
we could all buy bitcoin atms
yeah
that's why ethereum's so cool is because
the ethereum network is very very
heavily utilized and you use ethereum to
cover the gas fee which is the
transaction fee yeah so ethereum's
massively utilized people i think would
max say like 200k on bitcoin by the end
of the year i'm wondering if we're still
gonna hit that i don't think by the end
of this year but i think it will get
there i mean the thing somebody did the
math and like there's not enough
millionaire or what's a stat like
there's so many millionaires in the
world that each can't own one full
bitcoin you wanna know something funny
yeah if i invested my money in bitcoin
when max kaiser told me to i would be a
billionaire whoa
wow i'm not kidding there's a crypto
shiba it was like one of those doge
knockouts
all right so i put three grand in
four days later it's like 60 grand so
i'm like yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna cash
out if i held it another three weeks it
would have been like one or two million
or something
and i'm like you know what that's that's
that's you can't you can't be mad at
yourself the way i view it is this so
there's this this game i still online
it's like some gambling game where the
way it works is like you put in money
and then for every second that goes on
you get a multiplier so it could be like
after two seconds you get double your
money for everything is triple but then
it will go into zero at any random point
i think that analogy works for this sort
of high-risk trading where it's like
because it could be so easily lost you
really can't kick yourself when it does
take off after you sell because you know
if you're again playing that literal
gambling game you sold off you turned a
grand to 20 grand you could kind of be
an idiot to keep holding knowing you
could easily get out to zero so maybe
that's just what i tell myself to you
know not go criminally insane but it's
sort of how i see it i remember max used
to on his show he would talk about all
the different alt coins and stuff that
existed at the time and he was very big
on a lot of them now he's he he hates
them all he's like bitcoin is the only
true coin but i've known max for a
minute and he was he was uh pushing
bitcoin in the very early stages granted
at the time he was also pushing other
coins saying that these looked promising
for certain reasons like so what happens
is in the early days of bitcoin it was
like nothing was this weird internet
thing people were confused by
once it got its first boost of pop pop
popularity people started cloning it
there was a bunch of different versions
that tried tweaking different things
about it like it'll produce slightly
more or slightly less or work slightly
faster or take less energy and there was
one there were a few that required
substantially less energy and that
seemed to make more sense so max was big
on those
but
he had been you know so look i had i had
my savings back during those early days
and i if i just put it all in bitcoin at
the time bitcoin was at a couple bucks
the thing is i i tell myself like oh i
invested in a bitcoin when i heard about
it and was it 2012 it would have sold
out that's the thing i would have it
would have went from two dollars to 20
and then i would have wanted to you know
commit suicide the remaining uh 20 at 60
thousand there was a point where i had
like 20 bitcoin or whatever and i was
like yeah and i cashed it all out like
400 bucks and like i high-fived my
friend yeah and then i was like let's go
i'm taking you guys out to eat let's do
this thing it was just twitter accounts
like poorly aged things it was like a
scoreboard for some video game
tournament it was like first place a
thousand bucks and you get into tenth
place and it's 10 free bitcoin no it was
uh it was like first place is like a
thousand yeah place 500 and then it was
like fourth and fifth were 25 bucks yeah
yeah it that was it
but you know if people actually invested
and understood investment yeah they'd be
better off regardless people don't
understand the value of
like to invest and they
you know when i see my friends and
they're like i got paid let's go spend
it on drinks and partying and i'm like
if you buy something
you have that something it would be cool
if you could not you don't really have
to build a school but just build some
sort of curriculum where you you're able
to teach kids economics and the thing is
too it's there's a lot of apps now kind
of automated where you can just take a
hundred bucks at every check and put it
in so you don't even have to think about
it anymore you can just kind of have it
be on the back end i think there's
uniswap stuff i think uniswap's huge
yeah it's gonna i'll i'll say this
though so i i always say this as a
disclosure
doge i'm i don't think is gonna make me
rich i just think it's funny and so i
have some uh bitcoin is gonna skyrocket
in value i think a bitcoin is worth a
million bucks ethereum i don't know
where its cap is but there is there's a
funded amount of ethereum i believe
correct i think so yeah and we have a
general idea of the amount we don't know
the exact number so i think ethereum can
reach a certain level cardano
is i think there's like what ten times
more cardano or something like that
i have cardano as well because it's also
it's one of the guys was involved with
ethereum and so these are evolutions on
bitcoin that are going to allow so much
so i also have some cardano because i
think cardinals is going to score
there's 32 billion cardanos and it looks
like it's going to end up at about 45
billion somewhere there's 117 million
ethereums but there's no way there's no
end cap for those we talked about this
and i think you and i were saying we
think cardano would be like 30 bucks
yeah if you if you measure the value of
a token against so i go to this thing
called coinmarketcap.com and say you
look at bitcoin and how many 18 million
of them and then you look at cardano and
there's 32 billion so you do the math
you divide 32 billion by 18 million and
then you see but they're different
cardano is much like ethereum it's
providing the backbone for a lot of new
software right then you start to take
into account the utility and that's when
things break the mold so it's not just
it's not just one-on-one one to one how
many how much ethereum exists
117 million ish right
so i think what do we say it's like 30
times so it's probably gonna be like 10
bucks i think cardano oh cardano what it
would be what you could measure to be
valuable but when cardano was fully
launched and operating like ethereum
it'll be like what ten bucks
yeah you'd do like two thousand if if
cardano was
how you do but also
but also spot i'm not doing the math
right right the point is there's
substantially more cardano so it's going
to be worth substantially way less yeah
right yeah right uh because the the
circulation is massive it's just how
inflation works as well or partly so
they're going to be cardone should be
worth like a thousandth of a bitcoin at
any given moment or like less than that
because there's a thousand there's a
thousand times more of that yeah and an
equal market cap it would be one with if
they each have equal utility but like
you said cardano has a different utility
so you take the utility into effect
like mine's token you put one token on
the network you get a thousand views
that utility adds value to the other
thing is with so we we we had a
conversation about this a few like a
week ago and it was like we ultimately
came to like if if we are going to
randomly just throw darts at the board
and try and think of what it might end
up being based on the volume of it the
utility of it
bitcoin's going to keep going value
ethereum and cardano have utility
cardano ends up around 30 bucks
so i was like i like what they've talked
about doing i like what they're doing
i've heard a little bit about what
they're doing and i'm like i got to be
honest i don't know everything about it
i know ethereum works i know it's made a
bunch of stuff we're working on possible
it helps what mines is doing pos makes
it possible with utility tokens and if
they're going to offer up a competitor
to that i think it's going to drive the
value the cardano yeah yeah you did the
math right
measuring it as it stands you'd think
it'd be like 35 bucks something like
that that's that what 30 80 230 yeah
yeah yeah
so not advice to anybody because i we
we're literally just making up numbers
correct but i look at bitcoin as
decentralized transfer of value which is
tremendous and then ethereum and cardano
and any other token are like investing
in the network and i advi i love
investing in the network because i'm not
even super concerned with the value of
it uh monetarily it's the value of it
socially what can you what can it do for
us how can it cut out the middle man how
can it speed up transactions how can it
give you more reach on a social network
those are the things i love this is why
library tokens i'll tell you this like
maybe this is what you know the davos
types want
they don't want a federal reserve they
don't want a central bank they want
completely decentralized systems that
create global currency
look at bitcoin it is becoming that it's
a it's a global value network
so you can you can send money from here
to china just like that i've got a
sneaking suspicion we're all gonna have
our own crypto in the future everyone
will have their own kind of a social
security number yeah and then if you
have people buy your services if they
use your token to buy it you can give
them a discount
basically have that but no one uses it
so you have your own token yeah it's a
highly regarded token it's a it's a joke
i mean our stock taker is rtrd so
and i'm i i dude i was so angry i
ordered custom rtrd clothing for you
guys but it didn't ship inside oh i'll
wear it when it comes to
the same shipping facility two miles
from my house like four days in a row
and i'm
like all right i'll get it over somehow
blame the cabin yeah so anyway yeah you
can you can easily make your own token
and just oh it's it my friend did it in
like 20 minutes yeah then we raised
money for the pool and
i don't know how okay i don't know how
we raise money we literally put out like
on a on a medium page like hey um send
us money at this link and we'll give you
our new coin
and it looks like a scam obviously was
not uh people did we raised like 30
grand in a week and then we just put it
all into the pool well so this is one of
the big challenges the sec is not happy
with is people are using these tokens
effectively as as like fundraising
venues like shares right and so you're
basically telling people you'll get
you'll get this empty thing in exchange
for money yeah so that we can fund the
business so all the people that bought
our pre-ico i mean can sell at any time
and there's enough liquidity to make all
of them whole um so like they're you
know anytime they want to get out they
could all you got to do is pay your
sales tax on it yep and you're literally
just selling the digital asset it's not
an investment in the company you pay
your taxes on the it's like if we sold
these if we made a thousand little rocks
and sold them we'd pay taxes on it if i
can make a million tokens and sell them
just pay the sales tax on them there you
go yeah and if each token can get you a
little cartoon beanie
hell yeah nfts yeah beanie i i think
that the whole market stuff is
ridiculous it's funny but it is
effective and it's it feels like to me i
i really and i've said this a lot in the
last week it feels like what bitcoin
felt like in 2011 so made up basically
yeah like no one understands it yet it
seems cheap but it's going to be a
trillion dollar industry yeah it's
somehow but yeah digital if i don't want
to go out of their house if i well maybe
they do so i'll say this though if i did
listen to max and like legitimately
listen to him buy it and don't and and
keep it yeah i'd be a billionaire i'd be
a millionaire if i bled nft of a blank
space
there was no there was this thing back
in the day if you i don't know if you
heard of it where a guy had a million
pixels and he sold a pixel for a dollar
each
and it was a website with a million
pixels and then people would buy like i
want a hundred pixels and they would put
their art there
yeah i made a million there's actually
people who do there's a whole website
here where it's called where they buy
famous art pieces like worth tens of
millions of dollars and they issue
cryptocurrency on the art and then you
can buy up like shares of it yeah you
can buy a shares like a famous painting
and then then you get voting rights so
if they get a bid in for the painting
you gotta guys get a vote if you're
gonna sell it wow stock on objects yeah
but i think i remember i signed up for
it but i think you needed like tens of
thousands of dollars and it takes years
for them to so i wonder if we can issue
a stock on ian oh now i was just saying
that stock on people when is that coming
no aoc was who i was thinking about
there is they tried that yeah there's
some god there's an arc but who sold
shares in his life and he has to do
whatever they sell no no no um
he he they were out to vote but he had
majority control i think oh well then
you only own anything i guess well but
you know it was like he would take in
consideration their votes on what he
should be doing and they earned
dividends
so
when he would get a job and it would pay
him 100 bucks then he'd pay out 20 the
profit if someone bought stock in your
life and then as you went on you they
got dividends throughout your life talk
about a support they would support you
forever yeah but talk about nightmarish
i know that's bizarre like some young 18
year old kid he's poor and desperate and
he's like i'll sell you 50 for a
thousand please man i'm gonna be
homeless and then he's like a tech ceo
and there's like this evil guy like
behind him like i control it maybe you
could legally cap it so you can't sell
more than one percent of your own stock
i don't think she'll be able to sell any
of it because what happens then rich
people would buy up from young people
percent of everybody creating indentured
servants yeah yeah yeah good cause not
one for not one percent from everybody
like i said young desperate people and
then when they're older i mean that's
basically what college is doing yeah
there actually are services where you
can get a student loan and they get a
percentage of your income instead of
taking debt which it stossel did a
segment on it it makes a lot more sense
but they do cap it at a certain amount
and if you're unemployed you want to pay
anything that makes sense so yeah yeah
maybe that's better you just want to
cover the source book at all oh yeah
yeah bring it up let's talk about it
this is your new book yeah yeah so i'll
give you kind of an overview how it came
about um and then you know i'll go over
the contents and all that um so i've
been
the first book i did with my current
publisher was called spygate oh see i
should probably speak it to them
so it was called spygate uh me damon
gino and another woman named denise
mcallister wrote it and it was
i mean it covers all the russian gates
stuff it starts pre-election and then
goes into sort of the mueller special
counsel um he made it into a trilogy so
he did two books after that um on his
own one that's more all special counsel
stuff uh and then the last which is just
sort of everything after that um so
there's a chapter in the third book in
the series called or i care on the name
of the chapter but it has a lot to do
with ukraine and the whole impeachment
hoax um and there was some sort of like
soros ties ties into that chapter so
there's a number of um ukrainian
anti-corruption organizations that are
sort of back that were actually cited in
the whistleblower complaint um about a
lot of like the uh you know sort of
swampish characters in the in the
impeachment
saga or connected to you know u.s
institutions obviously that are um also
sort of tied in with soros so he pitched
the idea of doing a book where that was
swords that's going to be our starting
point was let's try to do a book
based out of that section of his last
book um so i put together a pretty
lengthy chapter i think it's like 15 000
words which is you know i would say half
the length of a very short book um but
obviously that itself is not going to be
a book um and you know i it was you know
really as much as i could do was that
much given the content or giving what
was available so it just became a
question of like well what do i want
people to know about this george soros
guy um and i sort of settled on
everything um so i started just by
making into a more or less a critical
biography so i start out by just giving
you know if you overview this guy's life
um who he is in his own words where he
came from how he made all his money um
what it was it made it want to go into
politics and influence that um and then
each chapter is just sort of a um
i mean i try to make it like biography
novel slash reference book so each
chapter is just a different facet of
life so we'll have one called soros in
the media and it's just here's every
literally every person in the media i
could find that soros is connected to
either um that he's associated with
publicly that uh has that have worked
for its foundations just varying uh
degrees and here's where they work today
and it's places like the la times and
npr and the washington post msnbc and
cnn on pretty much every quote unquote
mainstream place you can you could list
um and then it's just doing that for
everything else so i do one on his quest
to sort of infiltrate higher education i
guess in his view college isn't liberal
enough so he's trying to sort of um
actually this is a more recent end of
end of life sort of thing he's doing is
he's been creating his own network of
colleges internationally um and this
date's actually back to the 80s he
started a college um called central
european university in hungary um was
later expelled from hungary and is now
in vienna um but it's sort of starting
to build a network around that in recent
years um
and then i just do this for everything
so i i found for instance i have a whole
chapter on um leaked soros documents
from wikileaks and dc leaks and just
everything to be gleaned from them um
and then his connections and like just
random you know what's what's his goal
it it's to a large extent it's it's it
seems to be influenced for the sake of
influence um he is one of those people
that the you know not necessarily
takesinski or anything but the the power
process is very important to him um in
his own words too he describes himself
as an egomaniac he says he wants his
views to be the conscience of the world
um and it just seems like from his birth
he just kind of gets off on influencing
things um
you know the
the most interesting thing about the
book too is like you know some people i
know it's gonna be called the hit piece
but most of the negative stuff that i
say about soros and his personality is
quoted from him um i've read the guys
all the guys books in preparation for
the book um my own book i mean
the only thing he's walked back on was
there was a very uh i guess infamous or
famous interview he did was 60 minutes
back in the 90s um where he admits to
working with one of the nazis jewish
councils back in hungary um you know
serving deportations papers of jews
telling them their goods are going to be
confiscated um and very
sociopathically says that it's something
he never felt any guilt over um that's
the one thing he's sort of tried to
reverse course on and if you ever do a
google search for that interview they're
always playing cover saying oh it's
actually not really what he said um the
interview is actually kind of hard to
come by online too so i mean i i'm not
saying he's the kind of guy who's got
legal resources yeah i'm not saying he's
censoring the internet however he has a
lot of influence and he usually could
reduce its reach tremendously so he
actually found the transcript and you
you're oh i know and it's more or less
exactly what he says and not only did i
find the transcript uh george soros's
father wrote an autobiography he talks
about the same influence and it said
that his son seemed to enjoy it and he
tried to dissuade him from it you
remember when i think it was newt
gingrich was on fox yeah so and he
mentioned like george soros fun of these
da's you're out and fox was like we
don't accept that you can't say that
yeah so they had to apologize yeah the
only other two people i had to review
the book besides dan were newt gingrich
and steve bannon actually um and
gingrich obviously liked it and i'm sure
i'll make a joke about his fox
appearance next time i see him or i'll
talk to him but uh yeah that was very
odd um i mean i'm actually going to be
on fox hopefully to talk about the book
so uh there you go hopefully they'll let
me talk about it but uh
um but yeah that's just a sort of
general overview um the whole thing and
uh is it out now so it'll it should be
out in december
potentially might get delayed because so
we're nervous that we're going to get
sued not like a legit case but just to
sort of f with us and cause us money
because the libel laws are such like i
could literally accuse this guy of
murder in the book and i can't i would
win a lawsuit just because of how high
profile he is um but anyway we're still
doing a legal review just to like get
even that possibility out of the way um
and the lawyer like i'm sort of
paraphrasing but he was like really good
book interesting really well researched
um you're enough of a dick where it
could get you sued
so i have to they highlight it all and i
have to you know undickify the book but
you know hopefully it won't get delayed
more than a week are people able to
pre-order it yeah so it's on amazon and
martha noble and then i think all those
other random sites like books a million
or target it's probably on there too but
amazon's the big one um
give me the name again so it's called
the man behind the curtain um the secret
network of george soros um and uh yeah
i'll tweet about it and i'm sure you're
not gonna get it as well yeah well how
about we go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel
it is friday night everybody thank you
so much for hanging out all right jordan
olson typed a bunch of japanese i think
oh nice thanks jordan i can't read it
but he says the left has no idea what
they are dealing with and they are
pushing too far
well there you go
michael irwin says how dare the
journalists assume nicki minaj's gender
she seems to have bigger balls than any
of those insulting journalists that's
you know
redonk says nikki can handle her own ish
tim yes i know that's the point that's
why i'm happy because she is
when we finally have someone with power
and
an influence pushing back you know i
shouldn't say finally we've got a lot of
people who do but she is a juggernaut in
this space
she is the hero we need right now
andrea and zachary uh ifv fundraising
gofundme says the kyle rittenhouse
motion hearing today went very well in
his favor wreckier law did a good stream
for it earlier i think you'd like to
follow it oh that's very important we
should um we have andrew branca back
yeah we should we should we should look
into that maybe maybe have someone come
in uh look at that uh cigars and sig
arms says did you see the cow right
now's motion hearing today it seems the
judge is not having any of the
prosecutor prosecution's shenanigans he
may yet walk
kyle i just want to say for the record
kyle rittenhouse is my hero so
you know i don't know if i'd go that far
because he's a young kid
who who was trying to do right by his
community and the whole thing was was
crazy but when you break it down
the left is trying so desperately to
cover this up that's
i'm sort of being reactionary like yes i
understand he shouldn't have been there
however given the concepts of everything
but neither i wouldn't say that but
neither should the rioters so it's you
know
i would say uh
hindsight is 20 20. but when you watch a
video of a 70 year old man being bashed
over the head with a brick and left
bloody on the ground and then you say
i'm coming out to protect my my
community
should kyle have been there i mean i
should i should rephrase that it's the
the gun ownership is the only thing i
think legally there was some ambiguity
too
we talked we've had a bunch of others on
the show
no oh well good i mean i hope it's not
like yeah so we'll see how it plays out
i've been saying for a while i think
he'll get life because the political uh
uh climate there no one's gonna stick
their neck out when anthony was gonna
come to your house with a brick but hey
we'll see
all right let's see
bear exo says i'm glad ian is here today
after last night i thought tim
i'm not i'm not going to say that that
was a very eye-opening conversation last
night i thought a lot about waiting for
his cooking show i thought about
semantics and like what i don't want to
do is be like you said that so you mean
this i don't want to twist you with but
i like to talk about the meaning of
words and how words the meaning of words
are perceived by different types of
people it's very important to the to the
dynamic i think today right on the
praying doula says hey tim i watch you
every night so much so my husband calls
you the other man in my life can you
give a shout out to mr calvin wiggins
let him know he is still my number one
love you all you too ian
i like how she had you two ian as if to
like make sure she like i'm yes i'm
saying what's her name
the praying doula thank you the praying
doula and shout out to mr calvin wiggins
it would seem that your wife very much
cares about you so much that she gave
she gave me so much so she gave me 20
bucks so that i would say that's love
it's worth 20
there was a funny meme where some guy
was tweeting like a couple asked me if i
would uh leave my window seat so that
they could sit together and i said your
love is not as important as me watching
the airplane take off
and i'm like
yeah but like it's a funny way to put it
but like
bro
you're going to sit in a plane for a
couple hours
it's a good 4chan post but yes in real
life you might not want to you know
come on man
tim johnson says you were right i was
wrong the cops are a central problem
they could stop this god bless donald j
trump
yeah
the police so here's what's happening
freedom loving cops are resigning and i
get emails all the time they're like tim
i had to quit i couldn't do it anymore i
won't do this we have this story 11 of
15 restaurants that were surveyed by new
york post wouldn't enforce this
apparently you know libby is telling us
she was here on the show uh cops won't
even enforce this so there's still a lot
of good cops but a lot of the freedom of
loving ones are resigning then you've
got people in the military officers who
are resigning so what's going to be left
in five years well that's the unintended
consequence too of black lives matter is
generally speaking when cops are
demonized it's the good ones who know
hey if i'm ever in a tough situation i
might have to you know behave in a
certain way that might not be popular
they're the ones who leave then you're
left with all the crappy cops who are
sort of going to end up perpetuating
their narrative
the people willing to join and the
people willing to stay will be
establishment
chills
they'll be the fascists they'll it'll be
the banality of evil and so when people
are like if a civil war happened the
right has all the guns and it's like and
the left will have the institutional
guns and you will have the civilian guns
and so bad things happen
brett says nikki was blacklisted years
ago been working against the industry
machine and their plants eg fraudy b
she's the donald trump of hip-hop
i thought that was kanye wow
well i i like nicki minaj more and more
i i haven't actually listened to her
music you know i got to be honest though
i bet if you played her music i'd be
like oh i heard that song it's not good
it's not good it is not good of course
beauty is in the eye of the holder there
was like the weekend there was a time
whenever her song was whenever i don't
know come on i would turn off the radio
because i'm like if i die in a car crash
this can't be the last thing i hear
people like it i appreciate that um i'm
you know like i remember like didn't
bench shapiro have this thing where he
was like rap isn't music yeah 75 of crap
i mean it's a boomer joke but i think he
made that zoo change his mind oh really
he did yeah yeah yeah um
yeah music's music man oh yeah you can
raise and lower the pitch of your voice
as you're talking it's definitely music
yeah it's definitely music it's great
and there's some really good stuff i was
just i was you know i always really
liked the more political older older rap
stuff where they're actually saying
stuff and it's good it's good beats it's
good music it's good sampling and now
like we got that period in the 90s and
2000s where it was just like
opioid music yeah just i'm rich i'm rich
i'm rich i'm rich and i'm like this is
like i get it you can dance to the beat
but man there's no
there's no substance yeah give me the
heart give me the grind
yeah that's why there's like some pop
musicians where i'm like really
disappointed sometimes when they'll come
out with a song that's actually really
great in terms of composition but the
worst possible lyrics you can imagine
yeah and i'm just like wow imagine if
they actually you know
adele is good needs both oh my gosh yeah
she's great yeah fantastic
all right let's see okay
busted knuckle says tim had a powerful
quote today it's not about my opinion or
making this stuff up it's about watching
everybody else getting ready tom
mcdonald and nicki minaj collab omg
let's make it happen
i think i was basically saying like
uh the issue of civil war and and the
cult and everything
i said this a lot in various ways it
doesn't matter if you think you're right
it doesn't matter if i'm right or there
right what matters is both sides are
adamant they are right and they're
continually
put like in escalating the conflict now
i will say
as i often do
i think the cult is the are the ones who
are actually pushing it it's
donald trump did not invoke the
insurrection act donald trump did not
start these riots and donald trump
didn't even stop the riots
yeah but when it comes to joe biden the
executive decrees and cuomo murdering 15
000 people the left is right there
empowering them the entire time yeah
making it crazy you can like kill 15 000
people but if you make a few women
uncomfortable that's where they draw the
line that's where they draw the line
which i'm not saying what he did was
right but it's just of the two things
obviously one is uh quite a bit worse
than the other socrates was huge on
questioning himself and advising other
people to question authority and
question themselves i think we should we
should definitely keep that in mind
pepe clown says tim i'm gonna start
calling you three dog from fallout 3.
my ch my super chat is about you
claiming we have no culture on the right
just look at adam calhoun ryan upchurch
and all the other creakers and rednecks
we got culture bud we just don't got a
media presence
so
what i mean is
mainstream culture there's like almost
no right wing presence
obviously people have culture obviously
there's don't talk about it
well it's just the mainstream is owned
by the like the establishment culture
it's all owned by the law it's like it's
like five percent of it is right-wing
and they don't talk about it like i mean
like i think actually nor mcdonald who
recently passed away is sort of an
example of that or his you know if he
when he rarely talked about politics it
was right-wing but he was just like he
didn't have a thing where he talked
about going to a trump rally and how he
like he loved it or whatever yeah this
one joke where he was talking about how
how a transgender woman came up to him
and was like questioning like how can
you possibly believe in god how
ridiculous it is and he goes well i have
to pretend you're a [ __ ] woman
which is you know a pretty ballsy joke
from any comedian nowadays but i was i
mean it was from something within the
past few months but uh he did and he
gave no [ __ ] which was awesome but it's
funny that you know he goes on uh this
radio show and actually pushes back woke
talking points this is the that we've
been talking about for a while yeah
he pushes those talking points where you
know about
he was on a radio show with this woke
woman and he said
that black people are poorer than white
people and poor people are dangerous and
they all got offended by it but the
problem is that was actually their
talking point he just said it in a way
that came off as crass and they were
offended by it and it's like it really
makes you makes you think that
many of these people are offended not by
the substance of the idea or the fact
but by the way it's put to them yes like
learn to code the thing to they want to
know your motivation by arguing
something where you can say something
sympathetic but if they suspect it's for
the wrong reason that's also a sin
yeah true
norm was a master of the tone oh he was
the greatest he's so good there's never
going to be anyone funny or funny i hope
there will be i want to i hope there is
but yeah
yeah he's got there's so many videos
that are popping up of him
when he was on the view talking about
bill clinton kill the guy he's just
thinking about that wow that's the one
that was the one like saving grace of
his death and i'm like i'm glad
everyone's getting exposed to all this
because i i this is the dumbest thought
i always thought like oh only i listen
to this guy because i'm clicking through
youtube and of course millions of people
do but it was i loved him on the weekend
yeah best ever weekend update yeah
all right let's see
sea hennessy says a house divided
against itself cannot stand i do not
expect the union to be dissolved i do
not expect the house to fall but i do
expect it will cease to be divided it
will become all one thing or all other
lincoln
i don't think it will be united i don't
think it's possible it's just absolutely
not possible yeah it's because it's not
about facts it's about that i can sit
and ask someone a question
and they will change their opinion just
to oppose me
it's it that's that that's the problem
you'll sit down you have a conversation
with one of these people on the left and
and you'll say something and they'll
just say the apps well there's a whole
twitter account called defiant ls and
literally the entire feed no matter who
you are as a liberal he will find you
saying one thing and then four days
later imagine having the opposite
opinion in the opposite circumstances oh
he's just flying yeah he's an altar as
ezra klein had like the really famous
moment where he was like
you know um
we we we should have uh appointments for
the supreme court for life it makes
sense it's part of this country and then
when you know uh kavanaugh comes around
i can't remember who it was
jk
then kavanaugh comes and goes well we
really should consider limits yeah
people should be at a certain point and
it's like well the big one is the
vaccine which is i mean now getting
pushed on us as if you don't take this
you want everyone to die and you should
have no rights a year ago it was god why
is trump trying to rush this kind of
idiot would take this and literally
every mainstream public and including
including frank5021 from twitter every
single person did a 180. it's incredible
to see so
there's no way to mend when you can
literally sit down next to someone and
be like
trump wants this vaccine to be put out
they'll go that's a stupid idea you're
wrong and um well biden got elected oh
the vaccine's a good thing now yeah it's
like okay so we already got drake
reed tried to defend it by saying well
under trump it was just a different
regulatory process so now that it's
under buying and literally nothing has
changed since you know i still i always
seem to still find that when people come
face to face it's a different story
one-on-one not when not when mobs come
together well especially online too i
mean a there's a divide and then also
there's the acknowledgement that on
twitter your odds of convincing someone
of your opinion and 100 characters is
zero percent so text is not it's really
disrupting society right now this text
communication yeah yeah i've thought
about going off the grid once i'm no
longer doing politics dude just walking
to the river today was incredible yeah i
picked up my phone this morning i was
like i think i don't want to be honest i
think i think if i had everything now
but limited to like an hour a day it
would be fine yeah i think that's a good
budget i i will never get the willpower
to enforce that you can do it you can do
it
that's uh that's rob schneider josh oh
my gosh say tim and crew what do you
think of forcing politicians wages to be
the same as the median between the
lowest wages and the middle class wages
in their areas how would this affect
those who seek power in government they
would become desperate and then pony up
to establishment power to get a good job
after they left after two years so
thomas sold me at that point he actually
made a case and i don't agree with it
going this far but for paying everyone a
million a year that was yeah it's the
same thing yeah his logic was a the cost
per tax payer is like you know less
probably less than a penny when you
divide it between everyone and then you
know his arguments would make them less
susceptible to corruption now obviously
you could be you know super greedy and
want the million plus everything else
but that was his argument yeah money
doesn't solve greed yeah i think it
should be uh
that
maybe we pay really really well like
andrew yang said you know you get paid
uh a million bucks or whatever tom soul
apparently said the same thing but then
what if after you got out you could no
longer work in the private sector
that would be interesting because you
can't that seems to be the number one
job is just like oh this random senator
is now on walmart's board for some
reason how did that happen yeah so how
about you can't you can only work in the
public sector or
but
what if we we paid a million bucks a
year
and
then i guess the challenge is we there's
there's no simple answer to this problem
playing a million bucks won't solve
anything it's just make people want to
win so they can get two million dollars
yeah there's always a a workaround like
in india lobbying is banned but bribery
and corruption is extremely common so
it's like you just find a different form
for it and people don't understand what
lobbying is
you know typically younger leftists will
tell you that lobbying is like here's a
big check no mwahaha no they go to
dinner with the guy yeah they just
lobbied the influence really literally
lobbying literally means argue to person
well it was it comes from people
standing in the lobby and waiting for
congress the day session to end when
they would come out and they'd be like
hey hey come you want to come look at
this and they're in the lobby you know
lobbying exists yep
come to dinner with me to some extent we
need but just not you know for every
people
i really don't like people really don't
understand how simple things can be like
we've talked about gerrymandering
gerrymandering is one of the most
important things that we have in this
country when it comes to our political
system they just don't get it they show
a map and it's like here's dan
crenshaw's district and it's got like
weird lines and it's like oddly shaped
and i'm like yes
would you prefer it if half his district
covered the water
or if it covered large swaths of empty
farmland
no they're drawn over where people live
so of course they're not solid blocks so
this guy's actually a really solid
explanation of how you can
how everyone thinks that's what
gerrymandering looks like but he created
his own hypothetical map where every box
just looks like oh it's an evenly made
district and it was more gerrymandered
than the most gerrymandered districts
but it's just the placement of it
doesn't have to be the shape basically
was this point people seem to think that
like
chicago is a giant square
and you can just draw a square over it
be like that's a district they don't
realize that in chicago
there's big commercial industrial areas
like on the south side where it's
literally like five square miles of
factories
wrigley field for instance so yeah so
it's like we're gonna people don't live
there yeah and then there's also
mountainous terrains swamps places that
are not
incorporated so yes districts are drawn
where people live
and the problem is
whether intentionally or not you will
end up with a with a favorable
districting redistricting and so people
accuse each other both sides of
corruption for doing it the problem is i
think we have first passed the post
voting yeah one person one vote is is a
really dumb idea i can talk all day
about the founding fathers were
brilliant but this was one of the
dumbest things they did but i don't
blame them what is it first pass the
post what's in you one person one vote
it doesn't make sense
because we end up with a system where
people are voting against each other
right right as opposed to like a ranked
choice system where you rank choice 10
and then if the first person's off the
table it goes to your second vote didn't
new york try that i don't know how that
went when they uh yeah i think they do
it now i think they do rank choice i
think nebraska might or maine might do
ranked choice for all their elections as
well
um you look at the parliamentary system
where
i think that's actually in a lot of ways
better i would actually prefer it you
know compared to what we have i mean as
i said earlier i want to see more
parties right um so you know i'm a
republican but i'm
in a faction that i think 20 of the
republicans are in and so it's you know
yeah with uh with if if we had if we had
a parliamentary style voting system in
the u.s
you would end up with what is what is
the libertarian party like uh uh five
percent yeah probably five percent
so you would end up with what like uh
what would that be like um
like a couple two or three libertarian
congressman 20 in the house i guess it'd
be 20. what was this what 435 seats oh
yes
there you go yeah about 20 and then
you'd have yeah one or two in the senate
yeah
so the way that would work is any legit
uh you have five recognized political
party automatically gets so then most
european countries i think it's your
party has to get like five percent
although the threshold might differ but
then once you're above that it then they
get distributed based on that and then
coalitions have to form so republicans
would probably you'd have like a
republican party a libertarian party a
nationalist party and they might be a
coalition then you know the democrats
and the dsa might be a coalition and the
greens or whatever and what would happen
is the republicans would come out and be
like we want to we want to you know cut
taxes on the billionaires and the
millionaires and libertarians are going
to be like you bet and the national
population
the national populists are going to be
like we're not going to get on board
with that we don't see how that serves
the working class in this country but
the libertarians would often be like
anything having to do with shrinking
government we're going to say yes to and
then the national populists agree on
certain regulations the republicans do
the libertarians are going to be like
nope
so it forces but but then they could go
to the green party and say hey this
regulation you know so then they would
actually have to meet with more
different perspectives on the left and
the right to solve things i don't know
if it's it's it's would solve all the
problems though but i will say
first pass the post results in locked
districts and voting against voting
against people so now it's like we we
have the epitome of anti-elections
joe biden is an anti-president
he was not elected trump was
anti-elected yeah people went in hard
like i don't care about joe we don't
know or care who he is typically it was
the lesser of two evils now it's quite
literally anything
anything but trump that was their vote i
think too i think the mail in voting
probably also helped tip the scales and
that like if you're in a swing state and
you're some college like it's i'm
working with the premise that the people
that were the most anti-trump were the
youngest people who were also the least
likely to vote in the first place um so
like when you have mail and mass mail
and voting in any swing state you have
all these college kids who would never
in a million years would go to a polling
place can now just check a box
also but now people are going to say
like matt are you saying college kids
shouldn't vote
maybe
no no here's the way i'll put it
if you want to vote there should be at
least some responsibility some
requirement it shouldn't be that you can
sit there with your eyes half closed
someone knocks on your door and says can
you check that box for me real quick the
people think it's a virtue getting more
people to vote i'm like well what if
they're idiots like i mean it's not but
they wouldn't think that if it was more
republicans
so what happens is is what the democrats
have been doing
i i do not believe we're going to find
any widespread fraud i think i don't
know i think like uh bill barr said like
there's fraud but it's not that crazy
and i think that's i think it's correct
i do think we need security i think it'd
be ridiculous to reduce security we need
open source code in these voting
machines but what's happening is with
universal mail-in voting
democrats have all of these non-profits
to go door-to-door knocking on every
door and saying did you vote yet did you
vote yet did you vote yet it's right
there
before they had that they would knock on
the door and say make sure on september
14th you go vote and they go yeah yeah
yeah whatever yeah and then september 14
would come around and be like i'm not
going anywhere but now with a month of
print out your own ballots they have
that in california
if you're approved mail and universal
mail in voting now that the democrats
have a month to go door-to-door to all
of these people and say can you fill
that out right now
just fill it out right now you know you
got to fill it out and they'll go okay
fine fine i'll fill it out and
don't recall here done i'm done right
what do i do with it just put in your
mailbox mailman's come take it okay
that's what they've been doing
the republicans
don't have this ground game so there's a
lot of a lot of trump supporters who
think some like they were making fake
ballots and i'm like dude
they're real they're mailing ballots the
republicans helped him do it in
pennsylvania and then the republicans
did not go on the ground and that's why
republicans disproportionately vote in
person because they because no one in
the republican districts and you know
the other things it's harder to do when
you're a democrat and you walk into an
apartment building with a thousand
people in a massive building and you go
knock on one door vote vote vote you
walk 10 feet knock on the door vote
republicans got to go house to house to
house a lot harder to do that's why i
think universal mainland voting is bad
because it disproportionately favors
dense populations yeah
and we can't have that because they make
very very bad voting decisions
regardless of whether you think they're
votes right or wrong if you're giving an
advantage to those who live in dense
populations then you're going to
continually pressure left victories
right
all right let's see
there's a good one jacob kruger says
it's funny and scary that alex jones has
been write about so much yet still seen
as a whack job what's the difference
between conspiracy theory and facts now
a few weeks get nikki on the show well
alex has said a bunch of crazy things
that's why um he said a bunch of things
that turned out to be true and that's
fair but when he was on it like rogan he
was saying like the towers the internet
interdimensional beings and all this
stuff i'm like dude
the frogs are gay now when he said
they're turning the freaking frogs no
it's hyperbole so he's also hyperbolic
which i think has given him kind of
tainted his uh persona to a lot of
people because it was making them
hermaphroditic this this enzyme or
whatever it
um but not gay no not gay he's admitted
that so we've had steve bannon a couple
times and we get so many comments from
people being like wow i didn't realize
he was actually like kind of a normal
dude oh i found him a few times he's the
coolest guy i've done but people think
he's this fringe crazy far-right
neo-nazi guy because the media yeah and
for a lot of the people i think that's
why steve likes you like him on the show
twice he saw me on a show in like
december of 2019 and then like eight
months later someone just sends me a
clip of he's like yo yeah right i saw
this [ __ ] with matt palumbo he did a
great job and i was just i know i was
kind of blown away that he remembered
who i was i think um uh he he he came on
twice after the first time he was like
you know i'll come back and i think it's
because there's a lot of people who
watch us who are like fairly moderate
who have maybe only ever heard of him
from the mainstream media and then when
you actually hear him talk it was funny
he said he was far right and then he
says he wants to tax the rich and i'm
like steve that's not far right that's
like pretty left and he goes no i'm i'm
far right and i'm like no that's not he
was warm with populist and i'm like
right
right you're a populist and so when the
media says far right and you think it's
true i'm like
people don't understand what that means
you know but for for for steve bennett
to be like text the rich we're getting
ripped off i'm like that sounds more
like bernie than i mean it is more
common of the european far right where
they're like you know big on
anti-immigration but you know when it
comes to taxes they're you know more
liberal on that um
but yeah i mean he's not a you know
completely one-dimensional or anything
yeah he's really grounded yeah just i
don't know a very nice guy it's just
weird the uh the image that's been
created around him is like if
you know if i met him and he didn't know
a single thing i was like oh he's some
nice soul you know what i love about him
is he's excited yeah for the future it's
great to be around him
victor dimitrov says any plan for tim
cass to make games we are in desperate
need for more game devs that aren't woke
and aren't in the hellhole cities too
many games have sacrificed quality in
favor of pushing an agenda we have two
video games in development they've been
in development for some time it's
difficult it takes a long time
and we we're going to be incorporating
very interesting new technologies into
these games to make them alive outside
of the game as well it's gonna be
awesome we're working on a roguelike
game i've actually posted a video of it
we should probably
we i think we should we should maybe
make an announcement at some point about
one of the games
let's talk about it after the show yeah
because it's uh it's a roguelike it's a
normal game um and it's gonna be really
really fun and we're gonna make it an
immortal living game where like we have
regular updates different levels
procedurally generated stuff and we've
got a bunch of crazy ideas that are
going to make
probably one of the most fun games
you'll ever play the industries are
playability
are combining i've found all these
industries the movie industry the video
game industry the economics the it's
just becoming one the vr you know you're
gonna be in this world of reality
sub-reality
so we're stepping into that all right
dragon lady says dang it haven't been
able to be to be around the last few
days due to a hospital stay maddening no
internet reception available i feel so
relaxed now being able to tune in to tim
and lydia and i'm even glad to hear ian
i love you seriously hugs to ian
who said that i love you dragon lady
dragon lady i don't think dragon lead is
a fan of me
she'll get to know you excellent
rick ortiz says tim not financial advice
but do you have faith in both amc and
gmc's stunks also you're a nerd ian that
is true yeah definitely i have mcstuck
um and i and i i didn't actually buy it
when like the whole thing started
because i was like i don't want to do
that but i actually bought it because of
cover restrictions because i was
thinking two things
what is the one thing i want to do when
they lift restrictions moving i want to
go to the movies man that was my logic i
bought it and then the first meme wave i
just sold when it was like 20 or
something i got three and i was like
whatever i'm not i'm not gonna sell it
because my concern isn't making money
off of it my thing was like
i love going to the movies and i haven't
been able to and now we've gone to
movies a couple times it's fun and also
that says to me it's a good investment
you know why i bet a lot of people feel
the same way
so there's a lot of the super stonk
stuff where they're like by mc the short
people you know the
the mother of all shorts and they have
all this extra cash in their balance
sheet now that they can just kind of
diversify if they need to or or you know
use it to do anything makes it an even
better investment have you guys ever
been to an imax theater yeah oh yeah oh
geez i saw avatar in the imax yeah dude
go see an imax movie
what did i see i think i saw indiana
jones in the crystal skull
what's the paradox movie i can't wear
the hell it's called joseph gordon
levitt oh yeah
yeah i saw that imax it was very good
whoa
that must have been twisted imax is fun
i still don't know what happened but
yeah it was good yeah i fell asleep
during that movie
i don't think it was my fault brewmaster
monk says nft sounds like a great way to
prove you're at an important cultural
event like imagine getting one from
attending a concert and being able to
display these badges on a dating profile
that's a really good idea yeah we should
rip this guy's idea off but but that but
you don't need you don't need nfts for
that like so we're planning an event and
we're going to be sorting out the
details it's probably going to be
october 23rd
we could just issue a token and there's
only 300 of them
so they're fungible yeah but they're
there's just 300
right they're going to be nfts um you
could issue utility tokens yeah but i
guess you could do 300 nfts probably the
event yeah yeah that actually makes
sense because then you have it'll be
called like and then the data within
them will be one of 300 two or three
hundred three or three hundred and then
someone will be like i went to the event
and i got the nft three of 300 or one of
them and then the person is going to
want that number one
yeah big time and then what do you is
that all it is
yeah it's basically an art project yeah
at least right now it is there might be
better
uh utilities that come out for it
all right let's see
there was a super chat and it just
disappeared
and it was about cardano and i want to
read it oh there you go goblin hand says
tim you promised us charles hoskinson
what happened there when he's probably
in he's probably the coolest billionaire
you will ever meet and you can talk not
only crypto with him but liberty as well
he's a wyoming guy
i mean we we uh that's an open invite
yeah
we run in the same circles
come on charles
you can come on whatever wants to come
on wyoming's got great crypto laws i'd
love to talk to him about it oh what's
wyoming yeah oh isn't there senator
really into it yeah yeah yeah he's cool
speaking of secession why don't we just
like take over a state like that
it would be really exciting to start a
new community because they tried to do
that new hampshire the libertarians i
think they're working on it yeah
lord of avion says tim how do you feel
about the quartering saying you want a
civil war he doesn't listen to my videos
because like i've consistently said one
of the worst possible things for us in
the world would be if we if we fracture
then china wins and china is our
greatest adversary but it's funny that
he's he uses the leftist talking point
that by
talking about something happening you
want it to happen
that's like
it's kind of a
it's a weird thing to say
because it's completely irrelevant to
the conversation it's completely
irrelevant to the argument
if the atlantic writes a story saying a
historian says we're tracking like
ancient rome and we will have a civil
war and we've had a princeton professor
say it we've had numerous articles about
security experts saying it we have
leftist pundits and right wings pundits
saying we have sarah silverman saying
secede new hampshire's trying to secede
and then i go man it sounds like civil
war tim wants it to happen let me let me
offer a little counterpoint because if a
kid say for instance is holding a knife
and you're like hey put that down you're
going to hurt yourself then the kid
starts thinking i'm going to hurt myself
i'm going to hurt myself and then might
end up hurting themselves i think that's
psychotic
i know it is psychotic i think what
you're arguing right now if you tell
someone
it's kind of the way you phrase things i
think ultimately not you particularly
but just the way things are phrased to
people can kind of guide them towards
ways and maybe you've said things like
it's going to happen so i think that
means you want the counter point though
is that it really hurts stabbing
yourself
yeah as opposed to like put that down
it's safer if you put it down yeah
people have heart you know
i just i don't i don't think that makes
sense but the point is
imagine seeing a fire and then being
like that might burn the house now that
fire is gonna spread it's going to
spread he wants the fire to spread
what yeah it's the worst possible thing
it's going to destroy the neighborhood
and then and then the the the rival high
school is going to take over
and they're like he just wants the fire
to happen it's like okay uh i guess i'm
done telling people there's going to be
a fire you've warned us but now now it's
your job is to help us solve it that's
the crazy thing too it's like a lot most
of what i do is kind of just like
observational like a lot of my my videos
on conflict in china it's funny when
they're like tim poole so bias and i'm
like have you ever like watched one of
my videos that gets substantially more
views i will get way more views talking
about like uh uh if i did if i did
something on biden and the drone strike
and it's just like a drone strike was
ordered here the mill i did one segment
talking about 30 minutes the military
was was was reducing contracts in desert
theater warfare uh
ordnance and military gear and stuff
like that and was shifting to pacific
theater which was indicative of a
greater threat from china now that
especially with uh it also was a sign
that of the withdrawal with afghanistan
and it was ridiculously dry there wasn't
me going like i can't believe these
democrats are going
it was me literally saying
joe biden announced the pentagon would
be reducing its purchasing of and it's
just like 30 minutes of really dry stuff
and they accuse me of wanting war by
literally reading military reports and
purchasing reports and saying like guys
it really does sound like the us is
going to be shifting in this direction
and this will put pressure on china
thucydides trap blah blah
i think it's a ridiculous argument also
i think jeremy is a very much a
person-oriented show
so for me
when i'm like
take a look at this report about
conflict and the segment is literally
about the the
allusions to ancient rome and like
potential conflicts and history
repeating itself and then you have other
channels like jeremy where he talks
about people and you know what people do
it's just very different jeremy's not
going to make a video talking about the
merits of civil war
because he's a people channel you know
what i mean like
there are channels that focus on like
individuals and individual culture and
then we talk about that's why i usually
don't name people when i'll be like we
did it several times today i don't say
their names because i'm more interested
in the ideas that's being conveyed by
the person and not getting into petty
drama about them
also i didn't know he said that anyway
so i'm assuming he did but whatever
it's it's what the left says over and
over again like the princeton professor
can come out and say it and they'll let
they'll he gets a free pass then
kevin cruz douchebag or who oh it's a
princess professor that i hate but no go
ahead no
some prince of pressure came out several
years ago said we're in a cold civil war
and then i go hey guys look at that he
said like you won the civil war don't
you and i'm like no i really don't
because chyna will then take over
sarah silverman seems to want
balkanization though so that's good for
her yeah all right let's see we'll grab
a couple more
jim pina says you have a game project i
have 20 plus years in the industry so
i'll keep an eye on uh on this in case i
could contribute
we we re we need a lead dev
full stack dev well full stack i don't
know if they're going to do the game
stuff for us okay
let's go slow
one day at a time we need a we need a
legit game dev who knows um
what are we using game maker is that
yeah game maker yeah it's not even that
complicated it's just mostly tedious but
we need someone who can streamline
through these projects because
we got too much on our plates jobs at
timcast.com
and uh i think we might already have a
ton of people who applied but feel free
to email us and uh well we'll uh it's
friday night
we'll do one more jordan olson says love
your show please shout out smiley's
rescues a no kill cage free dog and cat
sanctuary that is run by my girlfriend a
freedom loving american right on shout
out smileys
thanks for hanging on this friday night
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel you can follow me at timcast you
can become a member at timcast.com you
can follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere you want to shout
out anything before we go matt um i'll
plug my own book for the second time uh
the man behind the curtain the secret
network of george soros on amazon martha
noble get it and i don't want to you
have another book too right um so this
is actually somehow my second book i
published this year or what i've
published um other one it's about de
blasio and cuomo um and just kind of a
brief history of them ruining new york
it's called dumb and dumber
gimmicky title but uh you know good book
obviously i would say that um might be a
bit dated now but i i think it's also an
enjoyable read where can people follow
you on uh on only on twitter
unfortunately the website's kind of a
hell site but um mattpolembo12 on
twitter um that's the only place i'm at
nice to see you hey man check me out ian
crossland anywhere on the internet love
you see you later
we were talking about nfts and we were
talking about rap and it made me think
one of my favorite artists called nf he
is a christian he writes about
philosophy he's very talented so you
guys should check him out for sure and
you guys should also follow me on
twitter at sour patch lids because i'm
very close to beating sour patch kids
and followers that's my only goal in
life
make sure you go to youtube.com cast
castle to watch the shenanigans that
happen every day in this facility which
are likely just to get more shenanigans
as more and more people come but um
that's one of that's our new our latest
show and our new show we're having a
meeting on to prepare for the launch
next week
graphics
marketing materials accounts all that
good stuff and we even have i think like
two episodes ready to launch it's a
great show you're gonna love it and you
know as i always say you just get
started we're gonna start it up we're
gonna slowly make it better and better
and better and we got a lot of great new
stuff coming for timcast.com so that
being said thanks for hanging out
everybody and we will see you all monday
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you